Can we just I just we just have an extinction event. Okay, I
don't [music] know. That's maybe that's the only way out. That's
the only way we ever get to stop talking about misogyny on the
internet. We just need an extinction event. Okay, I'm not even
saying it's not a problem. It you could it could be a problem,
but I just I need that to not be the discussion for like the
eighth year in a row, 10th year in a row, whatever the [__]
we're at now. I just need I need us to stop, please, for the
love of God.
The Schumer thing. [laughter]
Hold on. The Schumer thing happened as well. [music] >> do
you do you guys disavow Nick Fuentes?
Chuck Schumer pushing for a resolution for Congress to disavow
Nick Fuentes. >> Finally, on anti-semitism.
Anti-semitism in America has reached a dangerous tipping point.
Americans are facing threats.
>> Don't make them look good or reasonable is fair. I don't
know if it is. don't friends. I think there should be some way
to have a conversation with somebody that isn't like totally
attacking them the whole time.
That Oh man, I think there should be it's like you can make them
look like a normal person, but
maybe to me what I feel like needs to happen is you need to disconnect
the fact that this person's like funny or cool from the points,
right? From like their political movement, their political ideas.
And then even disconnect their political ideas, the good ones,
from what she sees as the bad ones. like you actually have to
do some thinking. You actually have to do some work. I don't
know if I'm I tended to be ideologically opposed, you know, in
the past to the idea that it would just be bad to talk to somebody
on a stream. I don't like that idea of like just saying you can't
have like a normal conversation
with this person cuz it normalizes them. I didn't like that before.
I'm starting to reevaluate it now.
I'm not sure exactly where my beliefs gone on that, but it was
it was how I felt before that like you should be able to talk
to somebody. you should be able to have a neutral conversation
with them that isn't just attacking them for old things they've
said or something. But there there has to be some way of like
[snorts] give and take there. If they're if they're like somebody
who's who's put a a ton of bad ideas out into the world and they
haven't changed any of them, you should probably ask about some
of them. I don't know if that needs to happen in the same piece,
the same like media piece, but >> harassment and violence
at levels we have not seen in generations.
And as I have said many times in this chamber, anti-semitism
is the canary in the coal mine. Where there's anti-semitism,
there works like there lurks white supremacy and other pernitious
forms of hate. Well, three days ago, the president of the United
States
declined to condemn Nick Fuentes' hateful views
and defended Tucker Carlson's decision to give Fuentes a platform.
The president was asked about his thoughts on the interview.
He >> I
man
trying to think of like where the arguments go in this too cuz
realistically Fentes doesn't need Tucker's platform. People are
doing the platforming thing with Tucker and they're trying to
I I don't know if they're like trying to rewrite this to go after
Tucker but it's not like Nick Fentes was gaining a ton from Tucker's
platform. I actually disagree with that. I think he was rising
meteorically.
the
oh the generational run had been going for months before that
Tucker interview, right? He literally fought Tucker and won on
Twitter. Like he fought Tucker and just like brutally raped him
using his dad's CIA record.
What about when Star uh I defended Stardust interviewing Richard
Spencer. I think that's the first time I was ever on Destiny's
stream actually is I was questioning Mind Waves on why he thought
that was like a good point to make. Yeah. So I actually defended
that back in the day. I just think you have to engage with like
some of the bad ideas. The other issue is I don't know how you
deal with people just like lying,
right? Like if if somebody comes on, they just lie about their
opinions. I don't know how you deal with that. You'd say like
here are their old ideas. They don't drive at all with their
new ideas.
I don't know. >> Decline to condemn Nick Fuentes. That
is disgusting. For Donald Trump to excuse and protect the spread
of Nick Fuentes'
confirms what many of us have long said. White supremacy and
anti-semitism are taking deep roots. >> Here's the thing
though. Wait, Porter Beller says Tucker is the number one political
show in the country and has a lot of institutional buyin. It's
kind of different from some random mid-level podcast. Yeah, but
Tucker had already talked about Nick and tried to Nick and then
kind of got his booty hole blown out and I think he saw that
it's like, "Oh, I can't just around with this guy. I can't just
like I can't just make him go away. Well, I guess I'll talk to
him." I think that's like actually what happened there. I don't
think it's People just don't understand
the exact
like the exact size Fuentes was and like how big how how much
momentum he had. Like I I think Tucker basically saw that he
had to either get on board or [__] off is what I
think his calculation was. Unfortunately, within the Republican
party,
just as we saw from the leaked texts of young Republicans, just
as we saw from text messages of administration officials,
the Nick Fuentes saga on the right reveals that anti-semitism
and white supremacy have been growing with disturbing currency
within the right wing and within the right wing of the Republican
party.
But I know this is not true of the rep of everyone on the Republican
side, especially not for many Republicans in this chamber.
Therefore,
I will soon lead a resolution here in the Senate rejecting Nick
Fuentes and his white supremacist views
condemning >> this is like the definition of a virtue signal,
right? Like the absolute definition of a virtue signal.
We're going to actually hold a vote. We're going to spend time
in Congress saying this guy's bad. We're going to we're going
to take this time. We're not going to read bills. We're not going
to go ahead and break up some of the mega bills that get passed.
And we're not going to do anything like that. We're going to
go ahead and we're going to disavow Nick Fuentes,
a podcaster.
>> Carlson's platforming of hate and condemning anti-semitism
and white supremacy wherever and whenever it occurs.
In the coming days, I will work to grow support for my resolution.
So the Senate
>> um as like a tiny thing I think you do harm here because
obviously this is playing into stereotypes like a couple people
are saying but I think you do harm one of the things that Fenta
is going to use to attack you is if you tie white supremacy and
anti-semitism together if you keep saying those are inherent
with one another right he's going to break that down into you
think white people if white people are happy and healthy and
powerful that can't be okay and you're going you like it's a
sort of betraying of your inner feelings that white people and
people can't coexist, that you want to put white people down
so people can rise. Like he's going to he's going to twist it
like that. I think it's just a silly thing to go through and
do this way personally. Yeah. Even though they're they're like
correlated, probably causitively related to or causally related,
but it's I feel like Chuck's not good enough to do this. Chuck
can't make these points. >> I can take a clear stand against
hatred and anti-semitism.
I hope my Republican colleagues will join me in this effort and
co-sponsor this resolution.
Calling out anti-semitism should not be a partisan issue. In
fact, when we refuse to condemn anti-semitism, when we stay silent
and fail to reject anti-semitic
>> When we normalize hateful figures spewing disgusting
anti-semitism, that is when anti-semitism spreads throughout
society like a poisonous wildfire. >> Very, very disgusting.
Americans don't want to see that happen. >> So my resolution
will give every senator, every single senator a chance to make
an important stand against hatred. The country must see us unite
and fight this awful form of bigotry. >> Wow. Wow. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Okay. Um I think a lot of people are reacting
to this as well. It' be interesting to see how most commentators
handle this like like Chuck Schumer spending time on this because
I think for the most part a lot of commentators get around this
by doing the old well I do disavow it but like
I I do disavow Nick Fentes's statements. I just don't think he
should be cancelled, right? And now this is like a total disavow
of Nick Fuentes by Chuck Schumer. He wants them to vote on it.
I think anybody who had that position of like I disavow Nick
but like not really. I actually support all of his ideas. Anybody
who's doing that to playing both sides thing, they kind of have
to stand with Schumer on this and they're gonna get blown up
if they do that. So, we'll see. Be funny to see somebody, some
people ride the fence on it. Quentes himself responded to this
clip. Give me a second. Let me pull that up.
Pull it up. Pull it up. Pull it up. Pull it up. Lol. I am leading
a resolution in the Senate to reject Nick Fentis and his white
supremacist views. Anti-semitism and white supremacy have growing
and disturbing currency within the right. Dot dot dot. We all
must condemn anti-semitism and white supremacy whenever it occurs.
Oh god. Drew Pavlu. Top top response from Drew Pavlu. I hate
Nick Fuentes, but this is stupid.
I told you. I told you. I feel like there going to be so many
people who like have to dance on this one. Did they just have
to dance? Cuz they won't want to. They'll be like, "Yeah, I hate
Fentos." But like, Chuck, no. Chuck, no. Chuck, no. I want these.
I want these views, man. easiest dodge for commentators is just
saying really this is what a senator is spending time on when
XYZ is happening in our country. Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I think a lot of people will say that. I think I just said
that. I think it's um I think it just looks bad in my opinion.
I think
Yeah. It's like you could you can agree and say, "Okay, I agree
with your your disavowel,
but it seems like a waste of time for people to just go only
that it's a waste of time." Probably a red flag.
A resolution to condemn a citizen exercising his First Amendment
rights. Sounds like a payday for Nick. Nick Fuentes, the Holocaust
denier. Dude, this this can't be a valid way to respond on Twitter.
Um, I I went and looked some stuff up in Perplexity or Grock
or chat GPT and actually there's the response. Look, look what
AI says about this guy. Look what AI says. Trump didn't refuse
to condemn Nick. He said he didn't know much about you.
About you? About him? Also, why is no one talking about the elephant
in the room? Nick is Mexico first. What?
>> You got a whole segment on your starts 107. It's annoying
when they say growers are a bunch of white dudes. I'm in Chicago
and the Mexicans love you >> Yeah. Yes, they do. THE MEXICANS
DO. I'M ONE OF THEM. I have one foot in both worlds. I'm I'm
>> Wait, was there a cut there? >> I have one foot
in both world. >> There was a cut there. I wonder what
get >> I'm I'm in the white world. I'm in the Mexican world.
Latinos love me cuz I I'm one of you guys.
I'm one of you guys. I'm a Latino that was for Trump. Now I'm
a Latino for uh We can't say can't say it. Not after. >> He
was going to say a Latino for something, wasn't he? Wait, I feel
like we need to go find wherever this clip came from. I think
that's what he was going to say there. I think that's actually
what he was going to say. >> Luke sent $30 as a fellow
Mexican. I >> just wanted to say how much I have and I
love the showa.
Thank you for being a role model. >> I love the bua and
I dude I actually do love Mexicans. I have love for the Mexicans.
They're good people. Honestly, the Mexicans are they're good
people. The patriotic ones, not these like psycho leftist ones
that want to destroy America. There are, let's be honest,
we don't want America to become Mexico. That being said, a lot
of the Mexicans that came here are very patriotic and very Catholic
and they just want to work hard. You know, that's not to say
we don't have to deport a ton of people. It's not to say we want
mass immigration, but Mexicans are good people, so I appreciate
that. We love them. We love these. We love the Mexican >> Kobe
80057.
>> Cristiano Ronaldo showed up to Trump's >> Wow,
that seems interesting. It's not interesting. It's It's him memeing.
>> finally on anti-semitism.
>> He loves anybody who's a Catholic. That's what he You're
just giving him the ability to say he loves anyone who's Catholic.
Isn't the Mex Mexican president?
I have no idea. Wait, is that true? Hit a early life check on
the Mexican president. Okay, now I've got a couple different
things here.
I'm not sure which one I'm going to first, I think. Hold on.
Give me a second. Give me a second. I'm trying to figure out.
I think we had Ben publish another video, right? Oh, this is
the Tucker >> Well, it looks like all these screaming >> Why
is Why is Nick's Nick Fuentes ish
I'm dying. I'm dying. I'm actually dying. Why is Nick Fentes
so popular? Nikki Haley's son explains.
Okay. Interview with Nikki Haley's son. >> Fuentes on the
internet is finally dying down a little bit. It couldn't go on
forever, though it seemed like it might. And that's a good thing
because after all, there's a lot else going on in the world.
Some of it important. And
watching people day after day stand up to basically make the
same point. I'm a good person, unlike him.
not that interesting or edifying or even really informative.
I mean, we definitely learned that there are quite a few professional
conservatives who are not that conservative in any sense that
really matters. Some of them are fraudulent or sad or kind of
stuck in nonprofit jobs because they can't get another. And your
sympathy goes out to them, but listening to them talk day after
day really didn't teach us anything. But it doesn't mean that
there aren't lessons to be learned. In fact, there's one really
important lesson, and this was really the reason to interview
Nick Fuentes in the first place.
>> The most important lesson,
it was Tucker didn't realize how he didn't realize how bad these
Listen, the most important lesson for me, this is for Tucker,
was that actually the collective guilt thing was something he
didn't really believe in. Okay, Nick Fentes actually convinced
him. Every person is guilty now. Okay, that's that's the risk,
Tucker. Okay, you platform Nick Fentes and he convinced you of
this. Tucker is actually just an open now. You hate to see it.
>> And the lesson is that a lot of young men in America,
mostly white, but not exclusively,
listen to Nick Fuentes really carefully.
And the lesson that
our professional betterers in Washington have drawn over the
past few weeks is that means they're as bad as Nick Fuentes.
They're not, too.
But of course, they're not by and large. They're just American
young people.
And so the question is, and it's a pressing question if you care
about the future of the country,
why have they been listening to Nick Fuentes
sincerely? Like, what is this? >> Why aren't they listening
to somebody from the Heritage Foundation or the Daily Wire? Why
do they believe Nick Fuentes more than they believe the people
who think they ought to have a monopoly on the attention of young
conservatives? That is a really important question. And what
is it? >> Uh, the answer is literally just that he's funny.
The rest of you guys are incredibly boring.
It turns out everybody you guys were propping up was just incredibly
boring. And you lose now because you didn't have anybody on your
side. There's one guy who was like a gay theater kid in high
school and wanted to be conservative and you guys tried to cancel
him and you put a chip on his shoulder. Okay.
If only you had other people who were into the arts who didn't
feel like conservatives hate every single artist ever.
I'm sorry. If you had some cultural capital, maybe you'd be getting,
I don't know, entertaining people. He's like the only entertaining
guy you've got. And every time you try to get one of the people
who's entertaining and like will tolerate you, like Theo Vaughn.
Every time you get one of those guys, you eventually put them
off way too much. Right. Trump like using Theo Vaughn's clips
for his own campaigning. You guys always get weird about it.
It say not simply about their attitudes but about the problems
they face, the society they grew up in, the future they imagine
for themselves. What does it say about all of that that Fuentes
is so popular among young men? After all, young men really are
kind of the basis of our hope for continuing as a country.
So if they're off in some direction that you don't understand,
it's probably incumbent on you to try to understand it to the
extent you can. You know, it's hard to understand other people's
motives and it's even harder when they're in a different generation.
But making a good faith effort to figure out what is this? Well,
that's on us. Us being, you know, everyone with a job who's not
in that generation, all the beneficiaries of a stronger, more
cohesive America, the America we grew up in, which doesn't exist
anymore. It's our responsibility to look at newer generations
and say, "What's going on with them? Can we help in any way?"
If we care about our country, if we care about our own families,
our children and grandchildren, we probably want to do that.
And it's probably not enough. I'm trying to think of like how
people would spin this into being like not spin it. But I'm just
I'm trying to listen for like the coded language way more.
You know, America does our America doesn't exist anymore. People
just want to people just care about their families. Like this
is it's not enough that you can accuse him of something at all.
But I'm just I'm trying to think of like if I were
If I were trying, if I were Tucker and I was trying to like covertly
signal support for these ideas, how would it sound? Like trying
to run those hypotheticals in my head? Because I think probably
a big place I disagree with a lot of the people whose political
opinions I respect otherwise. It's like
how much is this guy dog whistling? How much does he like truly
support Fuentes? In my mind, I'm like, he's got some principles
that don't really work.
And he definitely doesn't like Israel.
And I mean realistically probably the biggest one is just the
fact that he's like a Russian shell. But I don't know how much
there's like dog whistling going on here. So I'm just like I'm
listening for it. I'm trying to be I'm trying to be hyper permissive
of like the dog whistle allegations in my mind just for fun.
>> What's going on with them? Can we help in any way? >> If
we care about our country, if we care about our own families,
our children and grandchildren, we probably want to do that.
And it's probably not enough to call them names. It doesn't work
for one thing. It just makes whatever we claim to dislike even
stronger. There's one lesson of the Trump 2015.
Hold on. That depends on what the name is. If the label is accurate,
it shouldn't just make them stronger. If I call somebody a who
somebody that shouldn't make them stronger. I shouldn't be making
them stronger by calling them a right. I hope that's not his
argument here cuz you can't say, "Oh, well, calling Nick Fentes
makes him stronger." You cannot say that. That's [__]
stupid. announcement and everything that's happened since then
the last 10 years it's that
and the last and obviously is that when every power center in
the country declares war on you you become a power center doesn't
destroy you it makes you stronger certainly true for Donald Trump
would he have become president in 2016 and 2024 if all the cool
kids hadn't denounced him as an probably not would he been reelected
if the FBI hadn't raided Mara Lago and gone through his wife's
underwear drawer. We can debate it, but maybe not. Maybe this
would be the Ronda Santis presidency. Probably.
So, attacking people, particularly when you attack them ad homonym,
when you don't try to deconstruct or rebut the arguments they're
making, but just calling them names. No, it's
uh I don't know how to describe it for people. It's like you
can do the argument that he's not an you could say, "Oh, well,
you could just discuss the issues." I think you should do both.
That should just be the argument, right?
You should just you should be able to disagree with the ideas,
the actual things he claims, you know, are happening, the ideas
he espouses beyond
beyond just, you know, saying, "Oh, w or something." You should
be able to,
I guess, engage with the actual ideas. You have to do both. You
can't just But I swear to God, everybody who's like, I I just
get triggered now when people are like, "Oh, well, if you call
him an you make him stronger." No, that can't be true. I'm sorry.
on it on on its face he looks kind of like an he sounds like
an maybe you could make an argument that there's something core
missing there but realistically anti-semitism wit racism
um nationalism
nationalism with like social safety that's dude I'm sorry there's
like a lot there's just a there's a lot there that's counterproductive
every single time you expose yourself as hysterical and shallow
and you elevate them
in the minds of everybody body else. They're important enough
to be yelled at by every trustee at the Heritage Foundation or
whatever. They must be important. So again, it doesn't work.
But it's also on a deeper level kind of immoral. It's immoral
to dismiss
the concerns of your countrymen as beneath consideration.
I don't have to listen to you because you like some guy who's
got ugly views.
By the way, it's not a defense of all of Fentes's views.
We interviewed him on this show and said it is totally immoral
to hate Jews as a group because it's totally immoral to hate
any group. Period. That's always wrong. But it doesn't mean that
everything Fuentes says is wrong. It's not. I don't think people
are saying that either. I
h like level one thinking. It's It's crazy watching Tucker deal
with stuff that like was solved years ago.
actual years ago.
>> And more to the point,
what he says on the air and his huge popularity, which is only
increased the more these people scream at him, says a lot about
the people who were listening and their legitimate concerns and
the factors in our society in America and and the West that gave
rise to their attitudes like how did this happen? Let's for once
in the last 20 years
look back and ask ourselves an honest question. How did this
happen? Let's do what we didn't do when we withdrew from Afghanistan
or declared a truth. >> How did this happen? Oh, this could
be I mean there there could be interesting elements to this.
I'll see if I could I'm going to speed it up a little bit since
it's mostly a monologue. Okay. He's like laying out his thoughts
on >> We're carted away the rubble from 911
>> retrospective. Why did Fuentes rise?
Um, he was saying things that I mean,
October 7th's a big one. October 7th's a big one. Entertainment
Factor is a big one. Is there another piece? I guess embodying
like the actual race positions. Oh, being anti-immigration despite
what everybody says, right? Fentes was somebody who carved out
like a space on certain issues, anti-immigration and being anti-Israel,
right? He he carved out those those spaces for himself and even
when other conservatives ran away from those positions, he stuck
he stood on business, right? That gives you a little bit of
how do I put it? It gets you buyin from people
asked how did this happen? And no one was ever held responsible
for allowing it to happen or the bad decisions that made it happen.
Not one person. And so, of course, inevitably,
disasters followed disasters because if you never take the time
to take responsibility for what you've done or even understand
it, you're apt to repeat it. It's the most Oh, um,
what's another one? I think the the there's going to be a pretty
strong push for
the white identity thing. Not in a supremacist way, as in white
people should be able to collectively argue for themselves, especially
if they're on trend towards being a minority. You can't have
it so like white people can't gather, white people can't talk
about white issues, right? You're going to have to give up that
if this if this group of people is no longer a majority in the
country, then they are a group that can organize and and advocate
for themselves. That's going to be another big one is Fuentes
has always argued for well Fentes has just been a white supremacist,
right?
But unfortunately, everybody ran away from the middle ground
on that, which is, you know, every ethnic group should be able
to argue for themselves
>> obvious observation in the world is the basis of good
parenting. It's why you make your kids apologize of course. So
let's in the case of Nick Fuentes focus not on Nick Fuentes but
on the people who watch Nick Fuentes. What kind of world have
they grown up in? These young white men.
>> Well, that's a good question. >> They've grown
up in over the last 10 years a world that hates them and not
in a subtle way. Openly with a whoou like directness and ferocity.
They've grown up in a country that has systematically in law
excluded them from the workplace, from education, from federal
grants, and has told them again and again and again, "No, we're
not discriminating against you, and yes, you deserve it." Imagine
growing up like that. And again, this isn't behind the scenes.
This is way out in the open. And not only has it done exact >> I
mean I just fully feel like this is I understand that a lot of
people are going to disagree with this. A lot of people are going
to say no no this is wrong. It's not how you I feel like it's
probably true. I feel like straight up a lot of white dudes feel
this way. And realistically the arguments against them feeling
this way aren't even good. It's like it's not that like, you
know, every other identity group doesn't get special
privileges that white people are are almost explicitly denied
or were for a long time.
And it's not like people argue, oh, you wouldn't deserve it if
it were happening. They just tell you you would deserve it if
it was happening, but it's not happening. Um I What's the most
common response to, oh, like my I'm I'm being like discriminated
against as a white person. Well, I guess coming down from a position
of privilege actually makes you feel like you're being persecuted,
but you're just being treated equal. I don't think that's really
true. Are white people like it's all on a a level, it's all on
a scale that is dismissible by anybody who doesn't care, right?
That's the issue is like I don't think any discrimination against
white people is like that significant that you know you can't
rise above it, you can't be better than it, you can't you like
prevented from ever succeeding in life. It's nothing like that,
right? It's not really close to what a lot of other ethnic groups
have gone through in American history, even recent American history,
but it it has been happening. They've been yelling about anti-white
racism since the civil rights movement. Unfortunately, slime,
when the civil rights movement happened, white people were still
like a super majority in the US
and they had all the power in the US.
That's just not the case anymore. There is a lot more distribution
amongst different ethnicities. And if things are going to equalize,
you can't have the same attitudes towards white people organizing
stuff like that that you had from before. You just can't exactly
that to young white men. Of course, >> there's still a
majority in power and will be. Why? Why do you think that's the
case? >> White men being the one group who are officially
excluded under DEI. There's only one. It's white men. White straight
men. That's not whining. And by the way, this happens to be the
one group in America who by and large have been taught for cultural
reasons, don't whine. Don't talk about yourself so much. No one
wants to hear your story. And whatever you do, don't be the victim.
All of that's good advice, by the way. >> Sorry. Because
they are. Yeah, sure. I would say white men are still the group
with the most power or something. But I'm telling you that white
people in general as a race are
are they they're like attitudes in place that as they start to
lose majority status in the US, they're they're going to be problems
obviously and you can not accept that. But then you will fundamentally
never understand why people join these groups, why people believe
in Fentes or Big Papa fascist or anything. You don't get that
if you deny that the way. But this group has not only been excluded
with the force of law by the Justice Department in every state
and at every college and university with maybe three exceptions.
They've been mocked and attacked and lectured and heranged and
screamed at. Every bookstore in America had books on display.
Whiteness is the problem. Well, what if you're white? [laughter]
You know what? What if you're like 19 and you're thinking about
how do I make my way in this increasingly competitive, maybe
even ruthless country? It's just like the male loneliness epidemic
again, isn't it? I feel like every argument for the male loneliness
epidemic just applies in the the exact same ways to this where
it's like things were better. Um, they're probably not going
back. Need to find a new way forward. I don't know. I I feel
like it's gonna be a lot of replays of that same narrative, but
it's like really powerful because it's like your identity working
against you or you feeling bad about your identity, right? And
and basically there there would be groups who tell you you're
bad based on your identity and then somebody comes along and
they go, "Hey, you're not bad based on that identity. Hey, you're
not bad, right? It's just the same thing. Hey, you're not like
a just cuz you're a man. Hey, you're you're like a man. You should
[clears throat] be America has reached a >> Shut up, Chuck.
Shut up, Chuck." But that's that I feel like that's what it's
going to be right now. Now you need the guy who's going to be
like, "You're not you're not like bad just cuz you're white."
It's the same thing. It's just the exact same thing. And everywhere
I go, people are telling me I'm bad because the way I was born.
What effect would that have on you? And then you flip on the
tube or the internet
and all these people with big jobs make this just break down
to like the same thing as well where it's like
uh actually a lot of your problems are to do with other things
like you're actually kind of just a loser. It might >> in
big salaries >> definitely everybody who followed like
Andrew Tate Myron Gaines those people were losers >> who
have the implied moral authority of their positions are telling
you you're bad because of your skin color. By the way, this is
not
a guess. Here's an >> We have systemic racism in the United
States of America. It exists today and it's a white man's problem.
White men are responsible for it, not black men. >> And
we have stood back. >> I'm I'm sorry. Just factual statement
that nobody here is going to be able to deal with. White men,
least racist group in America, least racist group in the West.
Least racist group in North America by far. Not even close. Not
even a little bit close. White men, least racist group ever in
the history of of anything of the planet. Okay. White men leading
the way on anti-racism.
>> To see mediocre
>> Nope. Not after white women. Walk outside at 10 p.m.
and watch how white women change and give you their real attitudes.
Okay. White men are the people who aren't racist. White men are
the people who will walk by that homeless black guy cuz they
don't want to be racist and get stabbed to death. White women,
when it comes down to it, when it comes down to dying for your
beliefs, they'll cross the street, okay? They absolutely will.
Get the out of here, white women. >> Mely mouthed uh snowflake
white men who are incapable of taking critique, who are willing
to dole out infamous repudiations of the humanity of the other.
And yet they call us snowflakes, and they are the biggest flakes
of snow to hit the earth. American history is one in which white
Americans uh by and large have been taught to have indifference
or even contempt for black life. We have defined the country
as a >> um that can be true on like a micro scale.
This is sort of the argument for why a lot of white people don't
necessarily like care about the statistics around black people
being charged but around like black youth being charged. It's
why people are a little bit indifferent to how the police treat
black kids, right? I think that's that's true on like a micro
level. That's the issue with all the racial things is people
will say things, they'll overstate it, but it's like there is
a lot of truth in a lot of different ways to some of these statements.
What are other races equivalent to the clan?
I don't know. I mean, I I assume every race probably in the place
where they're an ethnic majority, like 90% has instances of things
like the clan,
especially if there was like a s like I'm sure there's something
in South Africa where the white people were actually like this
is bad.
I I guess they weren't even No, I we could just look at the actual
like anti- uh what do you call it? Anti-apartid movement, right?
Would have had a lot of people who
would have done some pretty evil, too. I'm I'm like too sick.
I'm too sick right now to have this discussion. I'm not I'm not
up on my stuff. But in general, I thought America was different.
Oh, I'm talking about America today. Wait, unless you guys think
the clan is doing like huge things today.
I'm obviously talking about right now. White men right now at
this point in history, least racist ethnic group, least racist
like racial group in the history of the planet. White men by
far, not even close.
Not even a little close. >> Nation where people of color
are here on a guest pass. >> One in three Americans are
racist. One in three Americans are terrified that this country
by the year 2040 is not going to be majority white. >> There
has been no oppression for the white man in this country. and
don't let it escape you that it is whiten >> I would say
this is probably true as well that there hasn't been true oppression
of white people in America that like the stuff happening right
now where people are scared of it it's on a theoretical level
and not a an actual level not a really has been implemented in
any way level even now even with like DEI at a tight
>> men on this side of the aisle telling us people of color
on this side of the aisle that that y'all are the ones being
>> wake up white men what the [__] is wrong
with you and you're just eating it up. Oh my god, look at what
they're doing. All of a sudden, my heritage is going to be over.
>> A few days ago, you were saying how people were underestimating
Fentes.
Yeah, I've been saying people were underestimating Fentes for
like the past 2 years. >> I won't I want to live in a country
where there white kids go to white schools and and white people
marry each other. What is wrong with that? I want to grow up
in a country that my great-grandfather grew up in. That country
doesn't exist anymore. So, you can see why there probably are
some Nick Fuentes viewers who are a little confused
when they hear themselves attacked as racist. Racism is wrong.
Of course, it is wrong, but they've grown up in a
I think Fentes realized how good a talking point that was from
the conversations with Destiny or whatever, right? Like, I think
that was when he had a had the panel with like Abba and Jion
and Sneo. I think Fentes realized when all of the black people
on the panel were like, "Wait, what's wrong with that? Wait,
what's wrong with just wanting kids that look like you? I think
he got that entire talking point. He like smoothed out that talking
point from those conversations. That's like one thing that you
probably could argue Destiny helped him with was I don't think
Nick realized just how much black people are like, "No, no, no.
You should be able to want black kids. That's totally fine. There's
nothing wrong with wanting your kids to look like you. Come >> World
where one of the leading CNN anchors is looking right into the
cameras. What the [__] is wrong with you white people?
You want your You want to be near other white people? You want
to have a heritage. You want to have white children. How dare
you?
The CNN anchor is married to a white guy. Whatever.
Wait, there's no way that problem transcends race or transcends
gender. That's like the most vehement like black or Latina
like woke warriors always have the white boyfriend, right? Turns
out even Don Lemon not immune.
He's got the white boyfriend, too. That's crazy. But it's a little
hard to tell people that racism is wrong when you're committing
And again, it's not just a few people. It was our entire ruling
class was lecturing us about how
>> uh Yeah, SDV Philly. Yep, that's true. That is the case.
That is exactly what I'm telling you. Yes, white men are the
least racist. Yet, Fentes, Trump, Tucker are political forces.
Yes, that is the >> Whiteness is a disease. It's a plague.
It's inherently sinful. It's the source of all evil. The president
of the United States stood up and said, "Racism is the problem,
and it's only committed by whites. It's a white man problem."
Is racism only committed by whites? No. And everyone knows that
hating other people is a human problem. One that every person
struggles with, hopefully struggles against. >> I'm super
dying. If Philly wants to argue this, I'm totally good to argue
it another night. I probably not going to argue it tonight, but
I would totally make time to have this argument with Philly.
Uh, but Philly, just so you know, I'm totally running with the
um I'm totally going to meta irony you to death. Okay? I'm totally
gonna I'm totally gonna like lean into this and make it funny.
Just so you know, cuz it's wrong. It's always wrong. Anti-semitism
is wrong. It's every bit as wrong as what you just saw. It's
every bit as anti-black racism, anti- Malaysian racism. It doesn't
matter. Hating people for how they were born is wrong. It's called
a universal principle. This country was founded on universal
principles. They apply to everyone equally. That's the promise
of America. That is Western civilization.
You could sum it up in a sense. What is Western civilization?
It's a civilization governed by universal principles. Everyone
can be saved. No one is damned by his nature. And hating any
group, because that's true, hating >> Hucker is just going
off on the same >> A group is by definition immoral. Doesn't
mean it doesn't happen. It happens all the time, of course, because
it's the default setting in the human heart. But we need to struggle
against it. Maybe not ban it. Hard to ban attitudes. And once
you get down that road, you become totalitarian
But say it's wrong. And if it's not wrong in every case, then
it can't really be wrong, can it? If it's not a universal principle,
then it's not a principle. And so, how can >> No, I'm saying
I will literally like make time. I'll like schedule this now
and do it tomorrow.
I Well, or the next time I stream, holy, >> my racism be
worse than your racism. Well, of course, it can't. So, the people
lecturing Fuentes viewers for >> Oh, sure. It does depend
on how you define racism. Um, white people are also the strongest
advocates for all the anti-racist racism stuff. Like, by far,
they're always the people pushing it. And white people are the
only ones who vote against their group solidarity thing. Okay.
Every other group massively votes in like along racial lines.
Whites, nope.
Nope. Not the case.
For something that is wrong, hating all is wrong. Totally wrong.
don't have the moral authority to make the case because they've
been engaging in this in public and in private for the entire
lifetime of Nick Quent's viewers.
So, it's hard to take them seriously. And by the way, you can
tell exactly where this is going. It's going toward violence,
tribal warfare. That's the last thing you want. That's why this
is a great country. That's why it's exceptional. Because we haven't
had that. And why haven't we had >> Well, hold on. Uh-oh.
Why haven't you had that? Now, don't argue homogeneity because
that's what everybody argues, Tucker. Don't argue that one. >> That
because we have self-consciously and out loud said these are
universal principles that apply to every human being because
every human being was created by God in God's image. That's it
right there. That's a Christian understanding of the human soul.
There's been a lot of noise in the news recently, but
to learn more. Well, so Bill Aman is all upset, you know, about
Nick Fuentes, anti-semitism. Good. I agree.
But where was Bill Aman when Harvard was systematically, as it
is today, discriminated against people on the basis of their
race? Straight white men. Harvard discriminates against them.
There's no guessing about that. There was a lawsuit about it.
We have the numbers. No one said a word. No one said a word.
Where was Paul Singer? These are now big Republican conservative
donors. Were they to be fair, I believe that was Harvard discriminating
most significantly against Asians, right? Weren't Asians the
one getting the short end of the stick there? I don't think that
was
I'll be real with you guys.
Asians raised in a white culture might actually be the superior
race. Okay? They don't get any of the pro. Like I think that
might just be true. Asians like second generation Asians might
be the actual superior race. That might just be true. I'm not
even Asian, but I'm telling you, they have like they have like
all the work ethic left over. They've got all of the like insecurities
and uh anxieties of their parents baked into them. They have
like infinite work ethic. They have intelligence. And they have
the creativity of like growing up in an individualistic society.
That might be that might be the perfect Okay. As close to human
perfection as anyone gets. Not joking. They upset. Did they say
anything? Did they do anything meaningful? These are billionaires.
If anybody
could have weighed in effectively against systemic racism, real
systemic racism, causing harm from >> Dude, I love this
stuff from Tucker. Hold on. Is Tucker about to go wait when the
whites and the Asians were getting discriminated against? Bill
Aman gave a ton of money to Harvard. As soon as he felt like
like they were letting people do pro Palestine protests at Harvard,
suddenly it was a problem. Suddenly Harvard was a big problem,
Bill. Why was it a problem when they were hating on the whites
or the Asians? Bill, Mr. Aman, excuse me. Seems like you're not
being consistent here, Mr. Aman. >> Promoting one group
over another on the basis of race. It would have been guys like
this. They said not a word or they certainly didn't do anything
about it. That's for sure. Now they're all upset. Well, that
looks like self-interest to people watching.
These for the fifth time are universal principles. The continuation
of the United States. >> Oh, this is broadly my point,
Philly. We might agree, is that like white people have had to
have like their reckoning with their own racism and they've broadly
decided like, oh no, we don't want to be racist. I don't think
any other ethnic group's really gone through it. states depends
upon those principles. They must be vigorously defended above
all by the most powerful people in our society. The people who
not simply have a voice but have power
to enforce those principles. The meritocracy is not just some
like goal that we should strive toward. It's the whole point.
You have to judge people on their behavior, not on their blood.
Otherwise, you move very quickly into collective punishment.
This is why what Israel is doing in Gaza is immoral. Not simply
because it's a bloody war where civilians are being killed. That's
very common and very sad. But what makes this different and worthy
of comment
is that Israeli politicians are saying out loud and Mark Levin
is joining them and saying out loud and a number of other Americans
are saying out loud, it doesn't matter if they die because
they're stained from birth by this sin. It's the opposite of
universalism. It's tribalism.
And it's certainly not unique to the Middle East at all. And
anyone who thinks it is is an idiot. It's the human condition.
It's a state of man. It's like the >> I mean, I don't know
if they make that point. I feel like definitely Mark Levvin thinks
that. I don't know if I've heard him say that that like, oh,
actually these Palestinians are just genetically bad. I don't
know if that's like they they're died in some original sin. I
don't I feel like they think that. I don't know if they say it
out loud. Like you wouldn't be able to prove that in any way.
most obvious that we
see it in this country too. Oh, that's outrageous. Really, Donnie
Deutsch? Is it outrageous? Did you say anything about the racism
all around you and the elite institutions that you're so proud
of being a part of? It was the basis of those institutions. No,
we're going to we're going to help some people and hurt other
people based on what their parents look like. So, why don't you
sit this one out? Actually,
>> okay. Kilo, you need to chill. Kilo, can you chill?
Kilo, can you chill in the chat? Kilo, you need to stop. you
be quiet for a moment and think about what the core problem is.
That's the core problem right there. It's not a defense of racism
or anti-semitism. It's all the same.
It's the only reason to oppose it. If it applies to you, it applies
to me. You should defend that principle as vigorously as I do.
And let's hope there's no evidence that's happening. By the way,
everyone's just retreating into their own little group being
like, "No, I don't want my people to get hurt." No, no. You don't
want any person in our country ever to face that ever. That's
why segregation was wrong. That's why the N were bad. I mean,
really, we have to have this conversation. Apparently, we do.
It's not an attack on everyone to point that out. It is not an
attack on anyone to point that out. It is instead a defense of
everyone. It's not an attack on anyone. It's a defense of everyone.
It's the only defense of everyone and it's the only way forward.
So, that's the environment that these kids grew up in. Racism
is wrong. Anti-semitism is wrong. How would they even know that?
How would they know that? Because you've been committing it.
Probably had no idea. The second thing to remember about this
audience, and I I'll just say I'm 56, so like how well do I understand
the coins as audience? I don't know. Probably not that well,
but I made some effort to to try to understand it again because
it's just objectively important. The second thing to remember
is that they have been attacked. Again, not making them victims,
not making excuses, just trying to explain how we got here. Can
we just make being a minority not a bad thing? Uh, that's the
idea is you want to make it not a bad thing. That's the the eternal
question. Can you just make
I don't know. We'll we'll find out cuz it's happening regardless
of what people want. It's definitely going to happen. For the
last 10 years, because they are male, because they are men or
boys and not just subtly with the overwhelming emphasis on female
achievement in school. And what about the girls? How are girls
doing? Well, actually girls are doing great. It's the boys who
are withering and dying, turning inside, internalizing the hate
against them, and as is so often the case, exhibiting it as selfhate.
not just ignored, but attacked out loud for being male by some
of the most powerful people in our society. Again, in case you've
forgotten, here it is. >> The level of misogyny online.
Um everything from literal threats uh against women in the public
arena to the demeaning of women to uh men with very large platforms
who uh espouse a kind of toxic masculinity
connected with violence uh brutality even sometimes >> you
know who my you know that's what we need guys we actually need
better role models better male role models has anyone checked
in on Connor the Valor media network I think that's like a big
time that's like counter points that's The real answer to Andrew
Tate, right guys? Isn't it Isn't that the real version of masculinity
you want? Someone who folds on all of their principles and paints
figurines,
plays games with their free time. That's like that's the depiction
of masculinity I want for my kids for sure. 100%. >> Um
is so >> okay. Wait, what? >> Connected with violence,
uh brutality, even sometimes
um is so shocking, but it's a reality. >> There's too much
of toxicity. It's masculine toxicity out there and we've kind
of confused what it means to be a man, what it means to be masculine.
We're seeing it with our younger people. We're seeing it in our
discourse and our politics, in the media. You're seeing it as
it relates to so many of the issues that we're pushing back on.
So, um, I think it's a problem and I'm going to continue to use
this platform every time I get to
>> Oh, you don't have to feel bad about the strays latigious
gamer. I just was driving a lot recently and I listened to a
whole like the Suneater series. I listened to like the whole
first book, long as book. It's like Dune mixed with Name of the
Wind kind of goofy book >> to speak out against this toxic
masculinity that's out there >> when they talk about Republicans
uh and their success online. They have been successful because
they have also been very clear especially >> do we really
have to roll we have to run back the red pill again? No.
Please find a different way of doing this.
It's like the red pill gamergate thing for the 80th time.
Can't we just
I thought it was going to be about stop bringing it back to this.
I don't want to do this again. I thought this was going to be
about >> especially digitally about what they believe that
women are inferior that do not and they do not deserve equal
rights. that they believe that LGBTQ Americans are subhuman and
they are able to radicalize and target and exploit a generation
of young boys in particular
away from healthy masculinity and into an insecure masculinity
that requires the domination of others who are poorer, browner,
dark.
>> Can we just I just we just have an extinction event.
Okay. I don't know. That's maybe that's the only way out. That's
the only way we ever get to stop talking about misogyny on the
internet. We just need an extinction event. Okay,
I'm not even saying it's not a problem. It you could it could
be a problem, but I just I need that to not be the discussion
for like the eighth year in a row, 10th year in a row, whatever
the [__] we're at now.
I just need I need us to stop, please, for the love of God. >> Parker
or a different gender than them. >> It's like And now for
today's lecture on masculinity from Alexandria Accaziocortez
and Doug Mhof.
I mean, you're you're tempted to dismiss this as once again the
unhappiest people in our society spreading their own personal
pain to the entire population. And of course, on one level, that's
exactly what it is. People with dysfunctional, incomplete, sad,
personal lives probably shouldn't be telling anyone else how
to live in the same way. >> Wow. No way. One second. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. I can't find the clip. >> I was
going to try to find a clip, but >> thoughts on Kosovo
sensitive talked about it all. Speaking of people with totally
broken social lives telling us all how to live. >> What
Israel is doing? RN is what Clinton said we were doing to Bosnian
Muslim and they bombed Serbia for that and when 911 happened
I was like now you care how it feels hoping you could do a segment
on >> I have no thoughts on Kosovo and I don't care. I
love when Balkan people ask me this so I could say I don't care.
What are your thoughts on Bosnia? What are your thoughts on Kosovo?
I'm not trying to be a dick about it but we don't care. We don't
care. We don't care. We do not care. What are your thoughts on
Kosovo and Serbia and Bosnia? America, we don't give a
Maybe they care about that in Brookfield where all the Serbs
live or whatever. Uh, but I do not care. [snorts] Okay, I'm sorry
to tell you that. I mean, I'm sorry that happened to you or congratulations.
I don't know what side you're on. I don't know what's going on
over there. >> Hold on. >> You didn't say Albania.
>> Don't think about it at all. And I'm not going to lie
to you. Hoping you could do a segment on Kosovo. Why? The show's
called America First. I'm a American, okay? And to the extent
that we talk about the other stuff, it's how it relates to us.
You don't see me coming up and doing a show on Wagadoo. You don't
see me doing a show about uh Burma and what's happening in Myanmar
and all that stuff. I don't care. Okay? Talking about Gaza cuz
we pay for it. Talking about Ukraine cuz we pay for it. Hoping
you do a segment on Kosovo. Okay. Well, ask your local Serbian
to do a show about that. I thought I was going to find a different
clip. I was going to try to find the clip of Nick with his monkey.
Okay. talked about getting married and then how he like couldn't
have a wife, but he needed a wife so he could get a monkey. >> I
wanted to hear I wanted to pull that up for the social life thing,
but probably wouldn't take real estate advice from a homeless
guy or investment [clears throat] counsel from Bernie Maid off.
Only listen to people who have demonstrated success in whatever
area they're lecturing you about. I mean, this is just like the
most basic life >> We're excited to announce a new partner
of our show, Poncho Outdoor. >> Men feel hostile to and
maybe you think that's a great thing. Certainly, if you're a
Democratic politician, you think that's great because that just
means more vote. >> Dude, is is Tucker just Hold on. Have
you guys ever seen Bert Chryser do his joke the machine? You
ever seen [clears throat] that?
Talks about going to Russia and he would just do bits from movies
that made him look super cool because they didn't have any of
the media there. So he could just do whatever. I think Tucker
is just running internet culture discourse from like 2021, 2022
because the boomers haven't gone through any of it. So he could
just run all of this exact discourse over again. just copy it
one to one. Replay it. Run it back. No new ideas, no new nothing.
He can just run back the whole gender war.
Do the whole thing. It's up voters for you. But if you're like
a normal person who cares about human happiness and thriving
and children and continuing your country and civilization, that's
a bad thing. So the question is, how did it happen? And if you
talk to young people, it's not exactly clear what the answer
is, but you notice immediately that the relationship between
men and women, boys and girls, is broken on a level it's hard
to see how you can fix. I mean, contemptuous of each other, suspicious
of each other, at some point dismissive of each other. That's
really what you pick up. There's hostility. Men feel hostile
to women. Women feel hostile to men. Could there be anything
sadder than that? Since men and women are designed for each other,
it's hard to become fully complete without the other. That's
not even a theological point. It's a biological point. It's true
for all species, male and female. That distinction is encoded
in all of nature in plants and animals. It's in the >> Tucker
is going to solve it. Tucker is going to send the solve the gender
divide. Okay. >> Universe, you just Tucker. >> And
you can ignore it and pretend that, you know, a woman needs a
man like a fish needs a bicycle. You can come up with any slogan
you want. You can externalize your childhood trauma in any way
you want and write all the books you want about how dad is bad,
but you can't get around nature because you didn't create it.
You don't make the rules. You either live by them and thrive
or you ignore them and are destroyed. That's the choice that
we face. Period.
I mean, you could say, you know, it's snowing outside. I'm going
to wear my underwear because I should be able to. Well, you're
going to freeze to death cuz it's not up to you. And the same
is true for the relationship between men and women. You can say,
I hate them. I don't want them. But you're not going to thrive.
Period. You will be miserable. And you just saw three miserable
people right on the screen. Wait, did he he said this to Nick
kind of right when they talked.
I feel like he said he said some stuff like this.
They had a disagreement. It might have been the most disagreement
they had in their whole conversation, right? Our society has
systematically, knowingly or not, it's hard to know exactly how
much was intentional, poisoned the relationship between young
men and young women. And they've done it in a bunch of different
ways. We could go on for hours on this topic, but the results
tell the story. They're not getting married because they don't
like each other. They don't know how to communicate with each
other and above all they think they don't need each other. And
that's a lie. It's a lie. So anyone who is promoting that view
is at fault. And when you're powerful and have a platform, a
megaphone, when other people are watching you and to cues from
you, when you have the power to convince other people of something
and to live a certain way, well, you're guilty. That's your fault.
So when I hear people say, well, you know, the thing about Nick
Fentes is he's a misogynist. He doesn't like women. Well, maybe
there's some truth in that and that's bad, but it's not so much
immoral as it is depressing.
That's the other thing. This is a group of people whose imagination,
whose moral imagination is so limited, and they're so narcissistic
in the way they see the world. It's all about them. Every person's
sin is an opportunity for them to gloat about how good they are
that it never occurs to them that this is a tragedy. If you hear
a young man say, "I prefer to girls or they're all and they want,
you know, money," and they're all they're all basically prostitutes,
which is kind of the argument that you hear,
you know, you should be very upset by that, very sad about that
and mindful of what that's going to mean in 20 years on every
level. On the most obvious level, like who's going to make the
babies,
but on a deeper, more human level, like how much misery is that?
A lot.
>> Like I don't necessarily disagree with what Tucker's
saying. probably would come close to agreeing.
It's so entertaining though. The [__] is this argument?
I wait.
Uh why do you disagree with what he's saying, Philly?
Why would Why would you disagree with this? Hold on. I want to
let you cook here for a second. You come on the stream. You just
come on the stream. I just got food. I'm trying not to be sick.
I'm very sick, but I'm trying not to be sick. You hop on if you
want. You want to join the waiting room?
>> I'm like dying, but I'll try to ask.
>> So, if you're adding to that, if you're >> said
misogyny isn't immoral.
Well, I think he said it's not like immoral. It's not wrong to
like hate women, but they're your companions. You got to love
>> If you hear a young man say, "I prefer to girls or they're
all and they want, you know, money and they're all they're all
basically prostitutes, which is kind of the argument that you
hear."
You know, you should be very upset by that, very sad about that.
and mindful of what that's going to mean in 20 years on every
level. On the most obvious level, like who's going to make the
but on a deeper, more human level, like how much misery is that?
A lot. So, if you're adding to that, if you're attacking young
men once again for how they were
Well, let me uh let me pull this back to misogyny is not immoral.
I missed I missed him saying that precisely. Stop >> of
what? That's >> so I'm going to pull I'm going to pull
it back to that. I want to listen to the context of that again.
Give me a second. Wait, what? What just happened? >> Yelled
at by every trusty >> wrong wrong. Oh, I just went. >> So,
when I hear people say, "Well, you know, the thing about Nick
Fentes is he's a misogynist. He doesn't like women." Well, maybe
there's some truth in that.
And that's bad, but it's not so much immoral as it is depressing.
That's the other thing. This is a group of people whose imagination,
whose moral imagination is so limited, and they're so narcissistic
in the way they see the world. It's all about them. every person
sin is an opportunity for them to gloat about how good they are
that it never occurs to them that this is a tragedy. If you hear
a young man say, "I prefer porn to girls or they're all slots
and they want, you know, money." I think he's saying that there's
a cultural issue right now where people are being convinced of
this without really meaning it without really understanding it.
I think that's what he's trying to say. Hearing this stuff shouldn't
be like professing these beliefs aren't immoral is what I think
he's trying to say. So when I hear people say, "Well, you know,
the thing about Nick Fuentes is he's a misogynist. He doesn't
like women." Well, maybe there's some truth in that.
And that's bad, but it's not so much immoral as it is depressing.
That's the other thing. This is a group of people whose imagination,
whose moral imagination is so limited, and they're so narcissistic
in the way they see the world. It's all about them. Every person's
sin is an opportunity for them to gloat about how good they are
that it never occurs to them that this is a tragedy. If you hear
a young man say, "I prefer to girls or they're all and they want,
you know, money and they're all they're all basically prostitutes,
which is kind of the argument that you hear."
You know, you should be very upset by that, very sad about that
and mindful of what that's going to mean in 20 years on every
level. on the most obvious level like who's going to make the
babies
but on a deeper more problem and you share some of the responsibility
for the results for the bad attitudes that inevitably will form
>> in the face of your hectoring.
It's your fault too. It's our fault too. That's just true. And
now we've reached a point where it's like an actual crisis
and our leaders are not
are not responding in a way that's going to make it better because
again they're caught up in their own dramas, their own tribal
dramas, their own personal dramas. It's all about them always.
You watch this Mandani thing going on in New York. Hardly an
endorsement of Mandani. I mean, please.
But like, what do you hear about the guy?
80% of the criticism of Dani is like his position on Gaza. Who
cares? What does it have to do with anything in New York City?
Who cares what he thinks of Gaza or BB? That's far away and not
relevant. This is a guy who said out loud on camera and then
once again out loud on camera defending the first time he said
it, "I'm going to tax white people more because they're white."
Did anyone even notice that? No. Because wait,
did mom Donnie say that? What? Hold on. Wait. This is a guy who
said out loud on camera and then once again out loud on camera
defending the first time he said it. I'm going to attack white
people more because they're white. Does anyone >> I I noticed
that? No. Because the people who don't like him have they don't
care because they don't see a connection between what happens
to those white people and what might happen to some group or
cause they're interested in. They're unwilling to defend the
universal principle and so they're just it's just more self-interest.
How dare you say that ABOUT GAZA? WAIT A SECOND. This is a mayor
of the biggest city who said he's going to he's going to tax
white people more. Well, you're just saying that because you're
white. No,
saying it because I'm a human being and a Christian and that's
not acceptable. Your leaders can't talk or think that way or
else it all just falls apart. And in a country that's the size
of a continent with 50 component parts, it could fall apart really
really fast and become super super ugly. And we are right on
the brink of that. Why are they misogynist? Maybe because you
told them the hormones they were born with were toxic. What are
they supposed to do with that transition? Well, a lot of them
did. Cut your dick off. The old >> Okay, this guy is really
behind. Actually, all of the miscantry is why men transition.
It turns out
>> of bowing before authority. You're right. I'll self-castrate.
And again, a lot did. But what about the ones who didn't want
to self-castrate? Where are they? Well, they're and they're pissed
at you.
They're mad at you and they have every good reason to be mad
>> Bro, I Incredible rant though. Like just missing on
like every single thing he says. Just an incredible rant start
to >> The third lesson we should take from the fact that
Nick Fentes, who everyone's busy done, Nick Fentes, he's the
problem, right? Yeah. He's the problem. Some 27y old goes he's
the problem. No, you're the problem, actually. No, I mean he's
also the part of the problem. He's also a very big part of the
problem.
I'd say the bigger problem was taking all of his views, the things
he was saying and being funny about and normalizing all of them
while trying to keep him cut out. So he hates all of you now.
I think that's a bigger problem for some of you guys. And the
third factor in his popularity is the fact, the uncontestable
fact that the economy the rest of us in our 50s, 60s, and 70s
people have all the money have created is destroying young people.
Just a fact. And it's not just that they it's not just that they
can't have, you know, the place in Greenwich and the place in
Jackson Hole. It's, you know, they can't have any place. They
can't have anything. They don't can't own anything. And rather
than
even spend a day thinking through like how do we fix this? The
answer is well, we'll just import people who are grateful for
what they're getting here because the differential between what
they got at home and got here is pretty big. Like if you're from
Waka
or Bangalore, like not owning a home in your 30s is fine. you
never expected to own a home anyway. So, you're just you're just
happy to be here and you're grateful to people who brought you
and you'll vote for them. That is literally their thinking and
it's demonstrable. It's their thinking. But for people who were
born here, what a betrayal. What a terrible betrayal and worse
than a betrayal. Here's just an overview of it. Buying a home
has never been harder. The average first-time buyer is now 40
years old. And it's more expensive to own. Nationally, the median
price of a home is $415,000,
up more than 50% since 2019. If you buy that average price home
now, the payment is roughly $2,000 a month. When you pay it off
in 30 years, it would have cost you about $657,000.
Just 6 years ago, you'd have paid $1,500 a month and about $563,000
total. The dream of owning a home is causing some Americans to
rethink important milestones. A new survey by Coldwell Banker
finds 71% of aspiring homeowners are postponing at least one
life decision, like getting married, having kids, or making career
moves until they can afford to buy a home. So, they can't afford
houses. probably
the top issue for young men in their 20s and 30s are a lot of
issues. By the way, at a time when they can't buy a home, the
idea of sending money to a foreign country, particularly Israel,
but all countries, any country, Sudan,
France, pretty offensive because it is after all their government.
They pay for it. You know, why wouldn't it offend them? But not
being able to buy a home, if you ask any young person, or at
least the dozen or two I've asked, number one, like I grew up
in a home, not an apartment, not section 8, not a rental house,
but like a house that I own. Not a huge house, but just like
a house could go to Home Depot, buy garden hose, fix the gutter.
Like that's kind of the dream actually for most men. And in that
home, I have my wife, my children, and my dog. Like, it's not
these are not crazy aspirations. These are the most human aspirations
men think about when they go to sleep at night. I think the issue
is Sophia, this used to be a realistic dream for people to buy
in like your late 20s being able to buy a home. Mid late 20s,
get your family together, start owning a home, used to be a a
thing. It's like my little house.
There's nothing more male than that. You know, it's my cave.
And they're being denied that. So, they're upset and increasingly
they feel nihilistic. And why wouldn't they?
But the question that too few ask is, well, why can't they buy
a home? Like, what is that? And you often hear dumb people say,
"We just don't have enough homes." Okay. Don't have enough homes.
We need to take
>> That's the problem. Canadian caller. This stuff's like
pretty easy to do. I feel like I just have like a real hankering
to try to start like a populist channel and like lean into a
character for it. I think I think it would be like really easy
to start that stuff up right now. The lines are all like very
easy. Convincing people they're getting over is very easy. I
don't know. We'll see. I like do it as a meme. Okay. I'll do
it as a meme. >> Like Yellowstone section 8 or something.
>> Morons. And of course, you know, so supply and demand
is real and so, you know, there are fewer homes than than we
would like to have and so the price rises. Okay, but that's not
really the whole story. There are a bunch of factors. One, big
companies buying homes and turning them into rentals. Why would
you ever allow that? If you want a revolution, keep that up.
Two is we just have more people. Density is a real thing. This
is a great country because it's not an overpop populated country.
It's not Bangladesh, not just because we're better than the Bangladeshies,
but because there are fewer of us in a bigger piece of land.
You don't want to live cheek to jow. It makes people crazy. Makes
rats crazy. It makes people crazy. Nobody wants that. But we're
getting it. And we're getting it through immigration. Illegal
and legal. We're being flooded with people from outside the country.
And we're like, "Oh, wow." You know, that's a that's a racial
thing. Okay. Maybe for some people there racial elements for
sure. Certainly a lot of cultural elements that are important.
But like at root, it's a very simple question. Has nothing to
do with ethnicity or even culture. It's like how many people
do you want? It's not about people. It's about how [clears throat]
the reason America Americans were able to do that
because America had a way of shipping goods around the country
of creating goods that stuff could be made in America could be
shipped all over the place and people could buy it. The and all
of the investment to make the goods was in America. The factories
were in America. And so the locality being next to those factories,
being able to go work at those factories was critical. you're
being paid for how irreplaceable your labor is. Now, your labor
is very replaceable in like every field essentially. So, there's
no reason to pay you a lot of money. There's just not there's
no logical reason to pay most Americans a lot of money. The factories
aren't here. Um, remote work is making it so that like you don't
have to get your development work, your your white collar work
done here. There's basically no reason to pay an American
the amount they'd have to get paid to be successful in America
unless they cannot be replaced by somebody from somewhere else.
That's that's just the facts. And
I'm trying to think of like what are those is like doctors, lawyers.
I don't know. Maybe the maybe the trades people stuff. Maybe
those people were all right. Why didn't the goods get cheaper?
Well, they did get cheaper for a long time. Now there's tariffs
and stuff, but even then even out even like with
there's just no incentive to I don't know. People like keep spending.
I don't know. I don't know why it hasn't been corrected economically,
but realistically, your labor is just way less ver valuable as
an American right
And people are going to consistently be hoodwinkedked into supporting
stuff that makes their labor less valuable. Realistically, techn
is getting good good enough that your labor is becoming less
valuable. You will have a less spectacular life for the the amount
that your labor is irreplaceable and better than the labor of
somebody from India has just gone down and down and down and
down. And people don't like that. People don't like it. People
feel like that's up. There's no reason that should happen. Americans
are factually less exceptional than they've ever been. American
exceptionalism isn't just a lie. It wasn't just a lie before.
Like maybe it could have been called true before because you
were right next to those companies. But Americans are less exceptional
than they've ever been. Companies deliberately ship the jobs
overseas because it's cheaper. Yeah, that's true. Almost like
Markx was on to something with the labor theory of value. I mean,
it's not even it's literally just common sense. [laughter] It's
just it's common sense. Yeah. I don't know. But unfortunately
with that equation, like you can never you can never make it
back from that, right?
Like there's there's no way to make your labor more special now.
It's never going back. I mean, sorry, it could go back, but unfortunately,
there's like only one way for it to go back in my opinion, and
it's just not going back. You're never going to get enough buyin
to make it happen. You'd have to have like a fascist American
empire that just basically takes the planet over. You got to
hope you have enough of a technologically technological lead
that you can execute that. And I don't know that America's got
the production capability anymore.
You you literally would have to like conquer. It's like
it's basically just resource extraction and like an iron boot
on everybody's neck. Branding. I'm not talking about branding.
I'm saying that's like the only way you get you get like basically
turning everybody else into slaves or your like plebeian class.
But then what incentive is there to even make it so like the
pleb class in America is better off than anywhere else? There's
not really. We don't need it. We can just get along with our
neighbors. Well, if you just get along with your neighbors, then
your quality of life is going to continue to go down. That's
you massively tax outsourcing and lower
I mean any any company that outsources can just go away. They
don't have to run their [__] in America,
right? Why would they have to run that [__] in America?
Like Fentes talks about this a little bit. A lot of people talk
about it. How America doesn't manufacture. They don't manufacture
anything.
And they've just got like financial and white collar jobs. That's
where the entire economy is. and you're you're advancing AI massively.
You're advancing like outsourcing massively. You're trying to
train up people in other countries.
it seems like there's just nothing that's going to make that
go back. There's nothing that's going to make Americans like
um valuable again. I don't know. If somebody sees like some way
around that, feel free to let me know. That sucks, man. Kind
of a bummer to tell you the truth. >> Living near you.
So many you can't afford a house.
That's kind of an overlooked byproduct of stuffing the country
full of people who are here because they're inexpensive to employ
and grateful to be here. It's a massive byproduct. But there's
another factor that's never mentioned and that's debt. Young
people are totally in hawk. They are completely indebted.
They have student loans. They were >> there's another big
one with the student loans to be honest. >> Required to
get a degree or told they were required to get a degree to get
some job that no longer exists because it's been eliminated or
H-1B or whatever. The jobs aren't there. unemployment among >> this
is the easiest rant in the world that gets everybody. By the
way,
I did this I did this the other day too. Humans need not apply.
Yeah, unfortunately humans need not apply is correct. But humans
need not apply basically applies like the the best case scenario
is like we sort of do UBI and and like people human thriving
is maximized and everybody's happy. What's actually going to
happen is only a handful of people are going to have that power.
I don't know. I don't know. >> College grads is out of
control. out of control. Are they becoming more moderate once
once they leave college? Like hundreds of thousands of dollars
of debt. They followed every instruction they were given dutifully
because young people are actually pretty dutiful.
And in this country, young people, some of them are really smart
for real. I think this is just broadly like I hate to say it.
I think this is just broadly the conditions at which like world
wars happen, right? Where like there's literally there's like
fundamental problems. the way the table is set, there's just
fundamental problems and nobody's going to be happy with the
status quo or like the broad like 99% of people aren't going
to be happy with the status quo, right? I feel like this is just
broadly when like massive wars happen. I don't know how they
even go about doing war now. I don't know. I don't know what
wars would even look like at this point, but I just feel like
things aren't getting better. I don't know how things get better.
>> Talk to them. I would love, man. Does anybody Is there
somebody with Hopium out there somewhere with like how how this
gets better? I mean, there tons of losers, of course, there always
are. But the smart ones are really smart and very aware of what's
going on. And they know that they've been completely betrayed.
They did what they were told to do, and they're shafted. They're
literally shafted because they don't have enough income, in some
cases, any. So, what are they doing? They're going into debt.
They have student loans.
They have credit card debt. And of course, now there are all
these other ways to borrow money that are disguised.
Buy now, pay later. What's that? You're going into debt. Of course.
I mean, I think it's some kind of communism. I lit I literally
think it has to be some kind of communism at this point.
Like,
I don't know. >> And what's so interesting about this,
and this is a problem primarily on the right, though not exclusively,
is that no one has sympathy for them at all.
Conservatives, hate to say this out loud, but it's true. Conservatives
have been trained to blame the borrower, not the lender. It's
like a feature of the mindset. Well, you took the loan, you got
to pay it back. It's your moral duty to pay it back. Pay back
what you owe. Don't be a dead beat. Okay. Total total debt default.
Exactly, Tucker. Total debt default. We just default on all
I mean, realistically, that's that's one of the few things you
could do. Unfortunately, I think wasn't wasn't America sort of
flirting with some stuff along these lines. America was flirting
with some some like uh some pretty crazy economic ideas and then
I feel like wasn't it China and Japan? No, it wasn't China and
Japan basically like long-term bond yields dropped massively
or something and it was like a signal that the US dollar like
people lost are losing
faith in the US dollar. I don't even know.
God, I I feel like I need to start going to
need to figure out what's going on economically in the world
again. I feel like I used to have a pretty solid idea and now
I feel like
now I'm mostly operating off of instinct and that's probably
never a good place to be. Hey, fine. Get it. Like it. But is
it really that simple?
No, it's not. Because the relationship between borrower and lender
is inherently symbiotic. One cannot exist without the other.
What other relationship is like that? What other fraught, sad,
diseased relationship is like that? Well, addict and pusher.
Of course, you can't be >> I know. For some reason, I was
just like, he's going to say Israel, isn't >> Drug addict
unless someone sells you
>> And yet, we understand the complexity of that relationship.
And we punish both. In fact, we punish the drug dealer more harshly
than we punish the drug addict because we understand that the
drug dealer is making all this suffering possible. And we feel
sorry for the addict. He's an addict. We can we can punish him.
And by the way, throwing him in jail might be the only way to
sober him up. It might save his life. And we should for his own
sake and for ours. Stop breaking into my car. Got it. But the
drug dealer, well, that we reserve our rage for him because he's
the one doing it. He's taking advantage of the weak. And that's
all true and that's appropriate to feel that way. It's exactly
right. But we don't feel that way about credit card companies
or student loan vendors or the guys who are literally offering
buy now pay later for Door Dash.
Some unemployed or underemployed college grad went to some crappy
college, got a warless degree because he believed in it. Now
he can't get a job at JP Morgan. >> Okay, hold on. Marty
Epstein's the only person I know who remotely understands this
stuff. So, I'm going to read his comments. They are they're long,
but they are informed. Our main export, this is America, since
World War II as being US treasuries. We've been able to extract
value from the rest of the world without having to manufacture
tangible goods because our government is the only one in the
world that can endlessly finance itself via endless issuance
of treasuries thanks to international demand from foreign countries.
is absorbing excess supply instantly, keeping yields on those
bonds low. Now that now that has been structurally changing with
increased capital flows out of USD.
A new popular hedging strategy for large in uh institutional
investors is going short dollar long emerging market currencies.
Huge flows out of dollar basically really believe it's why we
are posturing at Venezuela.
Oh, really? Interesting. H wait, how does how does postering
at Venezuela help this? How does I I don't even know
because I feel like the entire idea of the US dollar being the
most reliable currency is just the fact that the US military
backs it, right? Oh, because emerging market currencies are all
Latin American currencies basically. Oh, I wonder if this is
cuz I feel like isn't Trump trying to bump other people into
isn't he sort of thinking about applying this strategy? I thought
I'd heard rumblings about him applying this strategy to other
Latin America countries.
like basically the narot terrorist thing like that when people
like he might is it might be Colombia. I feel like he's sort
of been leaning towards he's like going to slap this label on
other people in Latin America.
Interesting because it's because at the end of the day we can
force people to buy a dollar if we have to via force. Isn't that
the truth? All right. Cool. Good to know. He's never going to
get one. And we are telling him it's totally cool to buy sushi
on credit. What?
He shouldn't buy sushi on credit. Obviously, that's dumb. But
he's a kid. Who's worse? The guy who borrows the money or the
guy who loans the money at some ridiculous rate?
Payday loans in this country. There are payday loans that have
a 600% annual interest rate.
And we kind of ignore it because we're like, who would take a
payday loan? You know, that's like a ghetto thing. Tucker started
off talking about
this is how you know Tucker's got some deeply seated beliefs.
Okay, he talks about the problems with men and women Nick Fuentes
and then eventually every rant he goes on ends in usury. Okay,
userie is the number one sin. At the end of the day, he just
always gets there eventually.
That loan money for interest. [laughter] Okay,
okay, fine. It's a ghetto thing. But who would do that to the
ghetto? Actually, who would do something like that? If somebody
said to you, you know, you can make a pretty good living exploiting
and degrading people, destroying their lives, would you do it?
Hope not. But if you did do it, the rest of us would have a moral
obligation to say, you are disgusting. That's disgusting what
you're doing. And we don't. And we especially don't on the right
because like it's immoral to criticize banks or something cuz
you don't believe in free markets.
Well, yeah. I wish we had I think Tucker's like actually this
is like way more correct than that's why when Trump did the 50-year
mortgage thing I thought he was just going to make it so like
it was a way I thought he I don't know how I thought he was going
to like actually make that a a deal for people somehow
like keep it from being I don't know like extra predatory. Didn't
seem didn't seem like that was the case though. I don't know.
Well, yeah. I I feel like there should be more condemnation put
on bankers, people who make a ton of money off of just running
finance schemes. >> You had them. Of course, I believe
in >> No offense, Marty Epste. Not you. Okay. Not you.
You're our favorite banker. You're our favorite guy involved
in finance, Marty Epste. Okay. Also, you're like the only person
in the chat now. It's like you and Sophia are the only ones who
are employed. So, we need you. We need you to keep it rolling.
Okay. Everybody else, we've all been fired. Okay. We're We're
done. We're all >> Free markets. Where is the free market
in the United States? and you find it, you got my cell.
But what we have to be against, and this is more important than
whatever you believe about the effectiveness of relative economic
systems, we have to be against exploiting and crushing people.
And if we're not, then what are we doing? And it's not even a
matter of banning it. It's a matter of saying it's disgusting.
30% interest credit card and that's totally fine. I must have
done 15 segments at Fox News about how Joe Biden's real sin was
making credit card debt non-dischargeable in bankruptcy. Oh,
who cares? Well, you're against capitalism.
If you want to make people against capitalism, let that continue
and they will absolutely vote for Donnie >> H.
[__] I actually super I way more than any other thing
he said here. That's what I kind of agree with. Man. Man, I didn't
even know Biden did that. That's like a great talking point right
there. Who's been Is there somebody who's been banging the drum
on that exact talking point right there? That's Oh, sure. You
could say that he's rich. I Does being rich prevent you from
making good points? That's a good point.
That's like a big deal. Making credit card debt not non-dischargeable
through bankruptcy. One, did Bidy actually do Sorry, did Biden
actually do that? Not Byron. Did Biden actually do that? And
then two, is there anybody who's like complaining about it? Cuz
somehow it does feel like Republicans would never have complained
about that. He's kind of correct. Hold on, let's take a look.
Let's take a look. Did Joe Biden make credit card debt nondischargeable?
via bankruptcy.
Okay, not single-handedly, but he he signed a bill.
Joe Biden did not single-handedly make credit card debt non-dischargeable
through bankruptcy, but he played a significant role in supporting
legislation that made it harder for individuals to discharge
certain debts in bankruptcy, particularly through the bankruptcy
abuse prevention and consumer protection act of 2005.
Joe Biden, while serving as US senator from Delaware, was a strong
supporter of BAP BAP CPA. Okay. Bronze Age pervert, chartered
accountant. What does CPA stand for?
That's what it is. It's chartered, isn't it? CPA.
I Dude, I'm I'll be honest. I think I'm getting a fever. I think
I'm I'm starting to like hallucinate and talk through stuff.
Certified public accountant. Jesus Christ.
Jesus. Jesus. We're having a struggle here. Okay. CFA, chartered
financial analyst. Okay. All right. So, he was a leader on this
bill, but I would have thought there'd be something that Oh,
people brought this up in the primary apparently that in 2005
he was a big supporter of this bill. Interesting. Okay,
cool. Let's continue. And they have, by the way, they have.
So, if you want to understand why young people are getting radical,
one of the main reasons is they are being exploited by the most
unscrupulous, richest people in our society and then being blamed
for it. And no one says a word about the rich unscrupulous people
who are doing this because everyone's taking money from them.
And you saw this in the last the Democratic the liberal administration.
So the idea was and it's true young people are being destroyed
by student loans. Okay, that's true. Who's benefiting from that?
Well, the colleges of course are benefiting because it's allowing
them to hire more administrators and they have professors. It's
allowing them to live in this kind of fantasy world where they
build this incredibly beautiful little biosphere in the middle
of some economically depressed hellscape in a rural area. That's
true of like every New England college. Bates College in Lew.
Ever been to Lewon?
Bates is beautiful. Why?
Because they're participating in the scam. Of course, backs stopped
by the federal government by student loans. So, they're the beneficiary.
They're the lone shark here. Actually, >> why didn't Tucker
just talk talk about this? I don't know if he realizes this.
Everything he said about gender issues was literally everything
he said was so stupid and everything he's talking about here
economically like like this kind of populist rhetoric. This is
like a thousand times more effective.
If Tucker was talking about this, he would be even more popular
than he is now. If Tucker like actually started to continuously
talk about this and so were the companies that are getting rich
from this. But what was what was the Biden plan? The Biden plan
was to stick taxpayers with the bill for bailing out students.
So they identify the problem correctly, which is kids are getting
completely screwed. That's terrible. And it's preventing them
from having productive lives, getting married, buying houses.
It's hurting them.
So who gets to fix it? You do. You have nothing to do with it.
You're probably paying your own kids tuition, but you get to
bail them out. And guess who's not blamed or punished? The beneficiaries,
the lenders. Just can't criticize the banks. Can't criticize
the universities. Oh, yes you can. Yes, you can. Because it's
>> Oh, this is going to go back to Bretton Woods, isn't
it? This is totally going back to Bretton Woods, isn't it? Uhoh.
And you know what? I never finish I never finished the book on
this. Oh, what is it? The the beast from Jackal Island or whatever.
That's like I think I've talked about that on stream before that
that's like the conspiracy book somebody suggested to me and
they're like this explains everything in US in US politics. You
read this book, you'll understand everything. It's Yeah, it's
the the book on the the creation of the Fed. The beast from Jackal
Island. Creature from Jackal Island. creature from Jackal Island.
Okay, got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. Yeah. And did you understand
everything? Oh, wait. Did I understand everything from the book?
No, I didn't. Keep reading the book. I stopped reading the book.
Um, the guy who suggested it to me is like literally 200 IQ,
like super genius who could work anywhere on the planet. But,
uh, so like he when he told me like, "Oh, this will this will
inform you on politics. like this is the best book to read if
you want to understand things on politics. I was like, "Okay,
maybe." And I started reading it and I'm like, "Okay, I get I
get it a little bit, but not exclusively their fault. >> It's
primarily their fault." And they've dodged all responsibility
just like everyone who's made life destroying decisions in this
country over the past 20 years. The truly guilty have escaped
not just punishment, but criticism. Yeah. That can't go on forever.
And in the meantime, it's creating a whole new audience, not
just for Fuentes, but for a lot of increasingly radical people.
Because that's what happens when you mistreat people and then
attack them for not liking it, is you make them radical. As important
as it is, politics is not the answer to this country's or man's
and worth it. We hope you'll join us. >> The good news
is that not all of them are radical. A lot of them are just clear
thinking and sensible and decent and committed to universal principles
of human rights and decency in that generation. The real surprise
here is how moderate
a lot of these kids are. You would expect them to be. >> What
was the book about? I think the book generally
I feel like it generally described that like the Federal Reserve
and a lot of government finance laws were created explicitly
to only serve banks, not really with like bankers basically wrote
all of the laws and that all of the protection, all of the risk
goes on to consumers and taxpayers. All of the benefits go on
to these bankers and there's like no real super there's no real
major downside for them. Everything they do is insured. All the
risks they take are insured and then when bad things happen,
it's always offset onto the taxpayers. Um it did allow for crazy
financing that probably did supercharge the US economy.
but yeah, it's at this point it just gets used for crazy financial
gamles. a lot more and they will get that way soon. But for right
now,
most of them most of them are decent people and smart. They know
what's up. One of them is called Nen Haley. We we thought a lot
before doing this interview. The one >> Yeah, I know. The
guy's a the guy is a conspiracy theorist 100%. The guy who wrote
the book, but you [clears throat] have to contest with like or
you have to contend with some of the ideas from the book, right?
>> Is what you'd have to do. we're about to do because
the man we're about to talk to is 24 and is the son of Nikki
Haley, the former governor of South Carolina, presidential candidate
Neocon.
And there's really nothing more immoral than using a child against
a parent. I've been a consistent and pretty strident opponent
of Nikki Haley's views for a long time. And so the idea of interviewing
her son and being like, "Doesn't your mom suck? That's disgusting
and we're never going to do that." Um, and so we had a lot of
conversations off camera with him before this interview. And
it turns out he really likes his mom a lot and thinks she was
a great mother and she's a great person. And he completely disagrees
with some of her views, maybe a lot of her views, while still
loving her and remaining grateful to her. And that in itself,
it's the most conservative. This is the most conservative like
leadin to an interview. He's like, "Yeah, I hate Nikki Haley
and her son hates her politics."
And this is like not me exploiting that. Okay, this is Listen,
we we both think Nikki Haley's like an okay person. Just trying
to cover his ass. It's just such a remarkable model of what this
should be the way that we should all be but increasingly or not.
And so we were delighted to talk to
>> Okay, we we are going to have the Nikki Haley son interview.
I'm not going to watch that whole thing. I'm going to go over
to the Piers episode that we had here. Okay. Benny Johnson, Steven
Crowder, bunch of people. Dan C. Oh my god, it's Dan Krenshaw.
Bro, I I need somebody I need somebody to get Dan Krenshaw
and Nick Fent Dan Krenshaw on some stream somewhere and have
him live react to the Fuentes clip. The Fuentes Crenshaw clip.
Okay, where is it?
Why don't I have it? Oh, I don't have it. HERE WE GO.
>> I'M DAN KRENSHAW.
Can you please respect Israel? >> That's the one. That's
the one. I need Dan Krenshaw to see that clip. at some point
before I die. Okay, I need to see his reaction. >> MAGA
versus Mega. Let's go. >> Nick Fuentes of course should
have a platform if he's not breaking the law. >> He's on
record saying he loves Hit. What does he mean? The plug's a idiot.
>> If you're not an anti-semite, why so much animosity
towards Israel? We do need to ask what radicalized them. Kuck
Carlson, Candace Owens, who are these
>> How did these people get radicalized?
All of the rad all of the radicalizers are sitting there going,
"How did we how do we radicalize these people? How did us persistently
telling these people that there's like a wealthy elite keeping
them down? How did that make them hate eventually, guys? I have
no idea. How do we how do we radicalize these people? Guys, how
did this happen? Where do we go wrong?
>> People, they're attention seekers. They're they're click
chasers. >> American politicians feel like they have to
be the world's daddy. And that's not why we elected you. Damn
it.
What's going on with my boys and in some cases gals? The words
of a perplexed president as he gazed over the enormous schisms
in his MAGA empire caused by the Epstein files. He could just
as well have used them again to describe the situation today.
Leading conservatives are trading woes and jostling for influence.
They want to define or maybe preserve America first for the postTrump
era. One side accuses the other of cancel culture and censorship
in defense of Israel. the other >> I do just want to see
like who identifies who straight up comes out as like
not on the America first side because there's a lot of definitional
stuff going on there to come out as like not America first in
some ways it's like sort of a death sentence for your career
>> says that Israel derangement syndrome has opened the
door to anti-semmites and extremists and when you look for it
the same dividing lines run through everything from the panic
over bombing Iran to suspicions over why the Epstein files are
covered up and they are set to run all the way through the contest
to succeed Trump. Axios is now reporting the senator Ted Cruz
is preparing a 2028 presidential bid that will lean into his
feud with Tucker Carlson, who is of course a very close ally
of the expected front runner, Vice President JD Vance. That is
an Israeli plot. Okay, I'm sorry. I hate to be the anti-semite
in the room on this one. Anybody talking about a Ted Cruz 2028
run, that is an Israeli plot. Israel is the only country who
cares about Ted Cruz. Nobody else gives a Shut up, Ted Cruz.
You're not the You're not the future of podcasting. You're not
the future of politics. Just shut the up.
>> Once again, it's MAGA versus Mega. And it's hard to
see how these two sides can be united to make sense of it. >> I'm
sorry. The fact that it's Migga, by the way, MIGA, not Mega,
not not What's up, my Miggas? Okay. Not nothing like that. It's
Migga.
Make Israel great again. Migga.
Vaga versus Migga. Thank you. >> It all. We're gonna do
things a bit differently and speak directly to some of the influential
people with different views on what comes next. Joining me first
is Benny Johnson, host of the Benny Show. Benny, welcome back
to Uncensitive. Uh I would never trust this guy. This guy
I'm sure everybody in that movement knows not to trust this guy.
This guy is totally fake. I don't know who owns this guy, but
somebody does. Somebody MAGA versus Mega. [laughter] Let's go.
Yeah, I'm sure you can sell some merch on that. I'm sure you
can [clears throat] sell some swag. And >> you know, I
could I could sell it to everybody that way. I I can cover >> Why?
Come on. How you going to come on here be the guy who's like,
I thought comedy was was back. I thought, you know, cancel culture
was gay. How you not going to make a a mega joke?
You're not even going to make a mega joke, Benny?
You
>> We're all racist. Turning to to the conservative right
in America, it's kind of fascinating to watch what's been going
on. How big a deal is this kind of schism that's been developing
and what do you fundamentally put it down to?
Oh, I just love this question and I've come prepared peers for
this with a prop here. And I hope that your cameras can can pick
this up and I I wish I had time to print it off, but there we
go. You can see here the fragments of both political ideologies.
You can see exactly what Piers was talking about with woke. Dude,
I Benny is creating his own meme format right now. Somebody take
the Kanye picture of all the companies and put it on this phone
immediately.
Okay. I need I need all of the all of the in red for at different
companies. That needs to be on this phone screen. >> Now,
the blue obviously is the left. the entire landscape of acceptable
thought on the left as chart as charted out by uh very reputable
and very good data scientists. The left is this teeny little
blue dot right there. Teeny teeny little blue dot. That's that's
what the left is. That's that's the arena of uh acceptable opinions
and thoughts was just talking about how illiberal actually the
Democrat party is and how illiberal and how nonprogress it's
actually regressive. Oh, I'm going to butcher my child and TURN
HIM INTO A GIRL. That's regressive, man. That's sick, you know?
Like that that's not that's not progressive. Uh that's like stone
age. That's like Aztec stuff. I mean, it's sick. But anyway,
this is the right. What a nightmare. And okay, I'll put the prop
down now. Um that's the right. I was going to print it off for
you, Pierce. I thought I'd save some trees here. You know, maybe
we'll bring in the environmentalist wing, you know, into [laughter]
the right. What I'm showing you here is that the ideology of
the right is insane right now and I love it. It is a very very
messy Thanksgiving dinner. Wait, wait, wait. You love the
wing of your party. Is that what is that what you're saying right
now, Benny? You love the You love You also love with our aunts
who have all been divorced three times. They've been hit in the
box of wine and they are ready to battle. And it's a lot of fun.
It's entertaining. You can put some of the videos up on Worldstar
of the aunts fighting, but we're all still under the same roof.
We're all still family at the end of the day. And this is a coalition
that has been created by Charlie Kirk in in no small part. He's
one of the driving forces of JD Vance and Donald Trump, RFK Jr.
and Donald Trump, Elon Musk and Donald Trump. These are this
is a world that is wildly different than like a Steve Bannon
and Donald Trump, right? And that's what you had in the first
>> How are we how are we still using St. Charlie? Uh this
is a huge party with a lot of competing interests and a lot of
people that care uh about making sure that their agendas get
done. And I'm one of them by the way. I have little pet projects
that I really want to see done and Charlie really wanted to see
these kind of things done like like the destruction of the college
cartel and the destruction of wokeness. >> The point is
here Piers is that the reason why it's messy is by design. It's
good. These are the good these are iron sharpens iron. The scripture
says it's important to train and it's important to spar and it's
and it just came from UFC. I mean, those guys, the fighters need
to have other fighters hit them in the face a couple times. Uh,
and when they're training, they got to prepare for this. That
battle is good on our side. Here's the thing that is bad about
it, because I know that's going to be your next question, so
let me just beat you to it. The thing that's bad about it is
disintegrationism. When people black pill and say, "I'm done.
You know, I'm done. Uh, I'm I'm cashing out on politics. It's
all rigged. It's all broken. It's too messy. Whatever. It's too
mean. People use naughty words." No, man. Don't leave the family.
It is a fun Thanksgiving dinner. The food's flying. Uh, the box
of wine is pouring. But in the end, we are all still family.
We all still won. >> He has the same cadence as pondering
politics. No, but there is a tonal thing there that is happening.
It's not the same cadence. Josiah doesn't talk like this. There's
no way. But there's a tonal thing happening here that is the
same. And that's it. Just as you said Josiah's name, I can hear
it and it bothers me. >> It's flying. Uh the box of wine
is pouring. But in the end, we are all still family. We all still
won this >> dude. No. Come on. There's no way. Hold on.
There's no way.
There's just no way. >> Neuroscientist, public intellectual,
and centristy liberal Democratic commentator Sam Harris finally
reappeared on the right-wing trigonometry podcast a couple of
years after his last appearance, which went viral, spectacularly
viral. And in this case, Sam Harris [laughter] Francis is old
now. What the once again brutally humiliated the two right-wing
diet maga co-hosts of trigonometry in a heated debate about Donald
Trump is he like zansed out Benny Johnson like Benny Johnson
is on speed and
Josiah's on Xanax but like there's something very similar going
on I can't describe it
>> of extreme diversity the only time here I'll say diversity
is our strength I don't agree with it any other time but right
here diversity is our strength is in the 2024 election, President
Trump not only won, but he won all seven swing states. He won
the popular vote. He won 90% of American counties that they were
woefully illprepared for. And some of these moments are truly
awesome. But before we unpack all that, if you end up liking
this video, few people do it better than Sam Harris, even though
I certainly have disagreements with him.
90% of American landmass [clears throat] voted for President
Trump. There's something there to that comparison. There's something
there and I can't describe what it is. There's like something
incredibly similar there, but it isn't cadence. It's not even
tone. I'm not sure what it is. No, there there is something there
is something similar there.
I don't know how to describe it. Also, this could be good, but
we'll see. Trump, uh, that is a winning coalition. It's a coalition
I want to keep together. I don't want the disintegrationist.
And I'll leave you with this thought, Piers. the way that you
fix it is America first.
>> Well, see that's fair. >> Look, that's very interesting.
What to which to which I would say, you know, Marjorie Taylor
Green obviously has had a big split with Donald Trump. She believes
he is now betraying the ethos of America first. Many on the MAGA
side say, look, Donald Trump promised full transparency on the
Epstein files and then renegadeed on that promise. He promised
no more engagement in futile. >> Yeah, Josiah is obviously
much I don't know much more honest than Benny Johnson. Not that
that's a high bar. I'd probably say that about just about anybody,
but foreign wars. Now he's gearing up for one potentially in
Venezuela. He promised that he would bring, you know, the prices
down and end the raging inflation, but inflation has continued
to go up. Prices are still very high. There's an affordability
crisis. I know you feel strongly about that. that there's a number
of things in the making of America first pledge box which Trump
is not delivering on. What do you say to to people like Marjorie
who say that? >> And Marjorie did go on CNN and apologize
for that and I think she's going to try and make good with President
Trump, but you're of course right about this and it's the constructive
criticism that make it makes it such a messy Thanksgiving. Listen,
if you if you love your friend, are you just going to watch him
like go home and uh beat his wife? you know, like no, you [laughter]
you're going to try and stop it. You know, you're going to try
and like prevent something bad. >> I think you called the
cops from happening. And I believe that, and I can tell you this
from inside of the administration,
uh, and the people that I talk with, that there has been an almost
intoxicating
effect that happens when you assume the most powerful position
on earth. Wait, hold on, hold on a second. Speaking of inside
the administration, apparently this happened recently. Now we
have this moment where right-wing anti-semitism
which seemed for a long time to be quite dormant or at least
[laughter] >> wait am I the only is this Chud
>> relegated to the fringes [clears throat] >> is
now entering the conversation in a big way particularly since
Duck Tucker Carlson brought Nick Fuentes on his show and Nick
Fuentes is talking about starting think tanks. uh he has the
allegiance apparently of people who are working in congressional
offices. Uh I've heard stories of uh you know him being played
in the background even in the executive branch in the White House.
And I'm wondering
apparently they just throw Nick Fentes's stream up in the White
House. Trump goes down to the situation room. They're about to
drone strike Slemani. He's like, "Could you put America verse
on right now?" Nicholas J. Fuentes.
Yeah.
Could you throw that up on the monitor? I just want to keep following.
>> How do you what do you make of this this sudden emergence
of this really virulent anti-semitism on the right?
>> Well, of course, as we know, it's been around for a
long time. And in fact, even when Goldwater
uh made that famous appearance uh at the Guard, he made a previous
one in New York the year before. There was a contingent on the
far right that was making the same charge that about the the
Goldwater and it was much more easily contained back then partly
because they had fewer channels, fewer outlets for expressing
those opinions and there was more of an of an organized
mainstream. Dude, I How many times do random people This is a
Sam [clears throat] Tannen House. How many times they got to
say
That basically implies they could control the media before. Well,
you see, the problem now is we uh there are just a lot of things.
It's hard to keep control of like a thousand different channels.
You see, uh it was a lot easier back in the day when we could
just, you know, crack down on a couple. Well, shut
stop, please. >> Media that was not going to allow those
voices to be heard. And the conservative media that Bachley dominated
in some ways mirrored the mainstream media. You know, a great
historian of uh conservatism, the Republican party guy named
Jeff Kabis service uh told me when I was uh writing a story I
think for Esquire magazine and Jeff was also the main uh first
researcher on the Buckley book. He was a grad student then. He
said, you know, Buckley's idea of an alternative media was his
own version of the New York Times. In other one that would be
as sophisticated and as well researched as well reported as taken
as seriously. It's that kind of seriousness that seems gone now.
That feels generational to me. And I know a number of people
uh are saying within the movement, this is the old guard against
against the new guard. And it's the old the new guard that has
taken up more of these memes and tropes that come out of that
uh you know sort of um murkier side of the movement. And I'm
reminded I'm sure you're well aware of it too that in the first
days of Trumpism there was talk about that about the alt-right
and Richard Spencer and these others who were either flirting
with or openly embracing anti-semitism
and real extremism. And that seemed to go away.
>> Right. Then you had the right the Freudian return of
the repressed and it's back here again.
>> Honestly don't know about any of the back half of that.
But okay,
I'm there's no way he could talk. No, Benny's got two more minutes
and then we're done with we're done with this after
two more minutes and Benny's gone. No, Benny's back. I can't
do more of Benny. I can go to other people. I can't do more of
Benny, bro. Benny's just yapping this whole time. Oh, this is
a lot of Benny. I might skip Maybe we skip the rest of Benny.
We let him finish the first part and then we come back to it.
I can't I I don't care about Benny Johnson's opinions. Oh, views
of Oh, he talks about Fuentes, though. I should probably watch
it. God damn it. Let's keep going. >> Donald Trump is often
called the president of the world. Multiple world leaders have
called him that. I >> Hold on. Don't compare Benny Johnson
and Crowder. Crowder is annoying. Crowder is a piece of [__]
but at least I can listen to to Crowder talk for like 5 minutes.
Listening to Benny Johnson talk just grates on my brain.
It's rough. I don't want to call him that, but that's what world
leaders have called him because the office itself is so uh unbelievably
powerful peers and you have military bases all over and many
c every second there's another world leader calling you for something.
And I think there's a reality distortion field in DC that has
been very pernicious in our politics in America for the last
50 years for sure since the Second World War where American politicians
feel like they have to be the world's police and they feel like
they have to be the world's daddy and that's not Ross Dutad had
Yorum Hazone on and they talked about Nick. That could be interesting.
Porter Beller, I will watch that probably when I go to sleep
tonight because that will be interesting to me.
Ross is good. can be good if he presses people. I swear to God
if that turns into Ross just like totally sucking Yorm Hzone
off. I I would hate it cuz
he should somebody's going to press Yorm Hzone on why the they
made the like the Kevin Roberts looks so bad. Why did you guys
This guy said venomous coalition. You basically had him at the
point where he was like crying on his knees begging not to quit
his begging not to have to resign. How the [__] did
you guys break down Kevin Roberts over this one comment? It was
insane. Not why we elected you, damn it. You know, we elected
you to be daddy here to care for your children, which are American.
And I think that that's how a lot of administrations, Trump's
and and many others have gotten sort of derailed and have soured
with the American people because they do focus so much abroad.
And it's like this lack of an ability to focus domestically here
on a country that has a ton of problems, like a lot of real problems
for real Americans. And they're the stakeholders in this nation.
They're the ones who elect you. Uh you should have allegiance
to absolutely no one else other than this nation and its voters.
And you should care for them like your own children. That's your
job. That's why we pay you. And and that it's actually your moral
duty in fact as a leader in this. >> Would you include
Benny? Would you include would you include Trump and the Trump
administration and indeed every American administration in modern
times the kind of slavish support for Israel? And the reason
I asked that question is because if you look at the split on
the conservative right, you can pretty well draw a line between
the likes of Tucker Carlson, Candice Owens and and others Marjorie
Teleg to a degree and others who have been critical of the Israeli
government uh strategy for example in the war on and those who
have steadfastly defended everything Israel has done. There is
a running line there developing between the two and Israel does
seem to be a common theme between the split.
Totally. >> Totally. Yeah. I'm I'm I'm just skipping to
the next. >> Talk to me about Fuentes for a moment. What
is your view of Fuentes?
What do you think? I mean, >> by the way, that by the way,
that's insane. Okay. So, like I just want to take this to its
logical fallacy. years. I [snorts] um have spent a considerable
>> Did he just say did he start saying I want to take this
to its logical conclusion and say I want to take this to its
logical fallacy.
I think that's what Benny usually does. He just wouldn't say
it out loud.
A little weird portion of the last few years on your show. >> Criticizing
Joe Biden and the Democrat party. And I believe that they deserved
a enormous amount of criticism. I personally believe that Joe
Biden was the worst president of my lifetime and will go down
in history as somebody who was so severely destructive to our
land and our nation. So, I'm criticizing Joe Biden in the way
he's running the government. Does that mean I hate
>> What? What an insane thing to say. Wait, what did Andrew
do? What did Andrew do? What did he do? What's going on?
Just did Piers uncensored today with Paleoc Christ. It didn't
go so well for him. So much so that he left in the middle of
the show. Who is this? Pushing the limits radio
hosted by Brian Shapiro, 20-year-old talk show veteran who covers
news, politics, sports, and entertainment live from Vegas.
What? This guy's a lying. I was having technical issues and was
dealing with the producer on them. I tried to cancel because
my equipment was overheating and I had to go live with an unstable
connection for a room from a room in my house. Me and this idiot
didn't even have much of a back and forth. I had the DMs with
the producer to prove it. Lying at liberals. Oh well.
>> Three baby daddies. Crazy work, my guy. Okay. Okay,
dude.
>> Yeah, we've criticized the UK government. You've disagreed
with me. You've said this and that and the and the mayor of London
and all this stuff and the horrible things that are happening
in the UK. Does that mean I hate the British people?
>> Like, of course not, actually. Like, no. You're invited
to the cookout anytime, Piers. Anytime. >> Well, I oppose.
You know, when I was a jolly old elf, well, when I was a newspaper,
well, Benny, when I was a newspaper editor over here of the Daily
Mirror, which was the Labour supporting newspaper, I very viciferously
front page after front page opposed the Iraq war before, during,
and after. Even when it put me at loggerheads with Tony Blair,
who was the Labour Prime Minister, you know, we were supposed
to be the pro- Labour newspaper, and I went the other way on
that war because I thought it was completely unjustified. Um
but again to your point the idea that by opposing what my government
was doing that in any way reflected my view of the people of
my country is completely [laughter] ridiculous. And the idea
that you the idea that you can't criticize the Netanyahu government,
which has some absolute headbangers on it, by the way, like Smodri
and Ben. The idea you can't cast a critical eye over some of
their decision-m without people assuming that you hate Israelis
or is just to me completely absurd.
>> Well, yes, and our taxpayer dollars are going to fund
it. So, in fact, we have a moral obligation. In fact, we have
a moral duty. Yeah, they're talking about Israel, dude. >> To
ensure that where our taxpayer dollars go, there are not horrific
things being done with them.
>> We have a moral obligation. >> What do you think
about Nick Fes? Well, let me tell you about the problems with
Israel first. Before I answer that,
let's just both agree that Israel deserves some criticism as
Americans to demand all of the Epstein evidence. I want to know
that we're not paying for a pedtorist ring. I want to know that
the American taxpayer dollars are not going to fund and support
and to protect people that were involved in the world's most
evil pedto ring.
Dude, there's no way he's saying this, right?
With this that's going on, Trump, Mike Johnson, everybody defending
keeping the Epstein files like hidden.
And now he's like, I just all the most important thing to me
is that I know I'm not supporting a global cabal. Well, why isn't
it the most important thing to >> that we know of right
now? Like I have a right, damn it, as an American to know >> So,
give us So, yes, give us the files
>> you know, and and there there were a lot of Israeli
leaders by Ahub Barack was one of them, some MSAD agents. We
now learning a lot of deals that Epstein was doing.
Dude, that's that's like just W lying right there. there were
a lot of Israeli leaders and then he names the one prime minister,
the one leader and then one MSAD agent who is literally I believe
the like the assistant or the like atache of Ahoud Barack who's
the the MSAD spy. He's saying these things like they're not connected.
The MSAD spy was the like assistant or some underling of Ahoud
Barack. That's like the connection. And trust me, I don't have
any insistence. I'm not trying to protect like Israel or something
here. He's just overtly lying. He's like trying to make it seem
like there's a way bigger connection there that you learn about
through Ahood Barack than there is. Although it's already a big
connection it's technically to the prime minister but former
prime minister.
But why lie? Why not just say connected to former prime minister?
You don't have to say a bunch of Israeli leaders with the nation
of Israel.
Uh yes, of course you can criticize that. Yes, obviously that
doesn't make you anti-Semitic. To say that Jeffrey Epste negotiating
a bunch of security deals on behalf of the nation state of Israel
seems extremely suspect if he's not. >> What is your view?
What is your view, Benny, of Nick Fuentes given his rising influence
and given he's sort of been become central to the debate about
where the right should go in America? What is your view of him?
>> Yeah. So we're in this country, I know there's other
countries that have different opinions, but in this country,
we are given by God a right [music] to free speech, thought,
and association. We're also given by God the ability to peacefully
disagree with each other. And I know that you've offered to interview
Nick Fuentes. >> Well, I've been thinking about it. I mean,
I had a I had a view before not to and I and then I watched the
interview that Tucker did with him and I just thought if I was
to do one, I'd probably do it a different way to the way Tucker
did. My only argument that I totally subscribe to Tucker's view,
he can interview who the hell he likes and do it how the hell
he likes. I was just struck that he was a bit tougher with me
Tucker than he was with Fuentes. So, I would certainly go harder
with Fentes. But I do think this argument of not
>> Okay. Why can't anybody say the name correctly? Is this
like a scop? Is this another scop who ain't tees
really people wi with with very very very small number of exceptions.
I do think generally speaking
you should platform people and then it's down to you to interview
them in a way that that adds to public discourse and doesn't
look like it just part of their PR machine. That would be my
argument.
Angel Studio, >> you don't and and inside of society videos
rise the police valve >> demanding truth and accountability.
>> I want to see Benny's response to that. But we're going
to release valve in >> and that that's how it's always
gone. >> And that's how the good ideas rise to the top
and the bad ideas fall to the bottom of the barrel. >> And
and inside of societies that don't have that pressure release
valve,
>> you don't want to see, in fact, you you do see the darkness
and the evil that arises in those societies when it's like, "SHUT
UP, SHUT UP, SHUT UP. WE'LL PUT YOU IN JAIL FOR THINKING THAT,
RIGHT? WELL, like that. That's actually the way to >> Yeah,
I I st like I need to learn, right? We just have to performally
signal about the foreign sounding name. Maybe I just have to
learn to skip anything involving Benny Johnson, no matter if
it's like attached to something I'm interested in. Benny Johnson
is just always the worst. That there literally wasn't really
a comment on Fentes. There there's basically nothing. It was
just a total waste of time. I feel stupid for allowing that time.
Well, joining me now is Steven Crowder, the host of Louder with
Crowder. Um, Stephen, great to have you on our set. I imagine
you probably were nodding away uh certainly for the last bit
of that uh conversation I had um with Benny Johnson, but there
are real issues going on with the conservative right in America.
And it seems to me the timing of all this is not unconnected
to the fact that we're soon to be heading into midterm year and
then after that into general election mayhem for two more years.
It is the beginning of the end of Donald Trump as president of
the United States, assuming he doesn't try and uh uproot everything
and run for a third term, which I don't think he will. And what
you might be seeing now is a kind of battle for the heart and
soul of where the conservative right in America goes post Trump.
Now, am I right? Am I wrong? What's your view? >> Well,
thanks for having me. I think I think you're right. Um and I
think uh look, and I I I know I just saw the last the tail end
of of Benny. We all know that we have the First Amendment. We
all know that we have freedom of speech in the country. I don't
think that's what we're discussing here. Like you said, we're
discussing the future of this country. Um, and there are some
rifts on the right, but I want to be clear, there's far more
of uh some civil fracturing on the left than on the right. So,
the through line isn't really just someone's extreme or someone's
old guard. The through line is clickbait. The through line is
you have a lot of people who have taken both sides of every issue.
>> This guy really can't afford
like fiber internet or >> so that they're kind of on they
kind of can't be attacked and your position is indefensible.
What I would like to focus on is a prescription for people at
home where they know how they can filter through people and these
commentators out there and maybe people they can trust. It's
five points I think. One, people need to ask themselves if we
agree the woke left is a threat because this is very important.
They're still out there. They just one of our friends and in
doing these change my minds on campus just uh two weeks ago at
Oklahoma University had to be escorted in an armed vehicle three
times because of threats, close calls. They're basically on their
deathbed figuratively. figuratively everyone just to be clear
and instead of finishing it the right right now is deciding to
infight. Number one, people need to look at this commentator,
whoever it is, whether it's Ben Shapiro or Nick Fuentes, whether
it's someone at Daily Wire or Tucker Carlson, and say, "This
commentator, this host, what have they done to fight the left?"
We have clear examples with Scott Preser, with people like Charlie
Kirk, people who have actually made a difference. What kind of
coalition can they build without without compromising fundamentals?
Let me explain to you, give you a really clear answer. Israel,
I don't think it's as big of a wedge issue with the half that
elects presidents as people think. My position said it to Ben
Shapiro over a decade ago. defund all sides of that war. Okay?
We shouldn't be sending money to Israel, nor should we be sending
it to Syria, Iraq, Jordan, Lebanon. Here's the thing. That's
a very reasonable position that many Americans hold and even
my friends have no problem with it. Can the people out there,
these commentators, build a coalition with that? If not, they're
not actually looking to build a future for the country. Let's
take H1B as an example. Ben Shapiro out there defending it. I
cannot imagine how anyone could defend this at this point when
80% of the program is antithetical to the reason of the program
because they're being put into junior positions. We need to do
away with it. Can the people the old guard can they build a >> I
mean no that is explicitly the purpose of the program. Stephen's
just taking what when people say oh it's actually just special
people. They're just lying. Trump is just lying to you when he
tells you that's the purpose of the program. You have an entire
program for the actual thing that is oh special like uniquely
talented people. You have a different program. That's not H-1B.
That's a totally different program of people. H1B is meant to
hire like young people. Absolutely.
Just these guys like these guys listen to the cope from Trump
and whoever the else Vivvac and and all these people. They listen
to the cope and they're like, "Oh, well, yeah, why why would
you support the program as it is then if it's so broken?" No,
no, no. That's the intention of the program. They're just lying
to you. >> The coalition with that. And finally, will these
people show up to defend their viewpoint in hostile territory?
I can tell you this. have extended an invitation to Ben Shapiro,
to Mark Levent, to Tucker Carlson, to Candace Owens, to Nick
Fuentes, and I've heard every kind of response out there, except
I accept those words. So, I don't know what happened to anyone
any time. I would platform Mao if he was alive today. Doesn't
mean I would agree with them. If Xi Shingping said, "Hey, you
know what? I want to have a chat." I'd make really clear why
I line up. Sure, we have freedom of speech, but we do have to
decide where we want to move forward as a country. And if we
get rid of Donald Trump, who's very flawed, who's made some missteps.
We can talk about that. Who are we going to replace him with?
Cuz now people are going after JD Vance. >> Do we just
want to serve leftist masters? Because I will tell you this,
I'm an extremist on that. I think that modern-day leftism is
a death cult. And if you're serving them by fracturing the right,
and you're just going to die, and I don't want to do that. I
don't want to die. I think there's still some wins to be had.
>> Do you think Marjorie Taylor Green is a traitor, as
as Donald Trump has called >> Today's show is sponsored
by one.
Well, that's exactly which Marley which Marjorie Taylor Green
am I talking to? Am I talking to the one who said, you know,
we can't deport people because it would hurt my construction
company? Or am I talking to the Marjorie and I disagree with
that? I think that's antithetical to MAGA. Or am I talking to
the Marjorie Taylor Green who said, uh, we need to do away with
H-1Bs, which by the way, I agree with. The only common thread
I can see between them is that you're very unlikely to have Indian
H1Bs in your construction company because they're are physically
feeble people. So, the his racism is like so performative. It's
like nobody even makes that point about Indians.
Like it how you like missing on racist. Dude, racism is so easy
to be funny with. How in the is he just not funny while being
racist? That's like the worst part. If you're being if you're
being racist and you're not funny, racism is like it's actually
just
like rocket fuel for comedy. Okay. If you can't win a race with
rocket fuel, you need to drop out. All right, don't do it anymore.
If you're going to be racist and you can't be funny at all, give
up. It's over.
Which Marjorie Taylor Green am I talking with? Which Tucker Carlson
am I talking with? Which Ben Shapiro am I talking with? The one
who said lockdowns are bad or the one who said that anyone not
getting a vaccine is an idiot. The through line here is not extreme
points of view. The through line is people pursuing clicks at
the cost of the future of this country. And I will platform anyone
so that I >> what? There are physically feeble people.
Could you say that any gayer? H
I don't know if you could say that any gay. This is like the
the dumbest opinion I've seen. I I I don't think this makes like
you can follow people and understand what their opinions are.
Maybe not as much with Marjgery Taylor Green, but Ben Shapiro
all of his opinions are like very consistent,
right? He where Ben Shapiro's like hypocrisy comes through in
who he hire is in who he hires. But his opinions in general are
fairly consistent. Okay, outside of the Trump question. I don't
know what is Stephen talking about that like Ben Shapiro supports
H1Bs because he wants clicks.
That's so stupid. >> I can get I can't answer these questions
as far as their views because I don't know them. For example,
Nick Fuentes, he talked about um he has an interview with Tucker.
Now, I want to be clear him saying I love Stalin, he could have
meant I'm fascinated with Stalin. There's nothing wrong with
that because you know who else is? This guy. I've been doing
a deep dive on Stalin and Trosky and this sort of infighting
that was taking place between them. By the way, spoiler alert,
I can summarize it. Two act fighting. There's nothing wrong with
being fascinated. And I'm not saying Tucker should follow up
because it's despicable. Because it's ridiculous because I'm
curious. And sometimes I'm wondering where the curiosity goes
when you have someone throw down some wolf bait like that. Well,
you love Stalin. What do you mean? You mean you're fascinated
how he was able to manipulate people? You mean all the people
that he You mean studying him to make sure we avoid it in the
future? Or do you mean that he had some cool threads and smoked
some cool pipes? I don't know the answer because a lot of these
people out there both the old guard republic. >> I think
it's probably the thing about your enemies and ruling with an
iron fist. If I had to guess,
if I had to guess it would be, you know, all of your enemies,
ruling with an iron fist would be the things he's fascinated
with and thinks are cool. ans who rightfully people have a problem
with them and this sort of new group of people they're not actually
communicating and they'll say that they'll have these conversations
but in my experience they very rarely will and I have a track
record of wanting to make that happen so again I extend the invitation
and I hope that you do too Pierce I hope you have Nick on and
then send him my way next >> I actually I actually am moving
to uh inviting him on because I think there's comes a point where
you can't ignore somebody's rising influence he is getting talked
about so much right now that he's exuding an influence over people.
You know, I had the same argument really with [clears throat]
someone like Andrew Tate who I've had on a few times. Um I think
it's important when someone has a big big following uh and are
saying whatever they want to say unchallenged that they come
on to somewhere like he hasn't Nick been on peers before. So
Nick would have definitely been on with Kanye, right? Were Kanye
and Nick both on at the same time? Kanye was on at that time.
I can't remember if Nick and Kanye were both on. >> I I
literally can't remember. Sneo was definitely on with Kanye,
>> but I don't know if Nick was >> here where I don't
come against some partisan political ideology. And I challenge
everybody, right? And I think that's actually a valuable exercise
in public discourse. We don't live in the old days where people
only had mainstream media outlets to do this stuff. You know,
people online now can have exponentially higher audiences like
Fuentes and as their influence rises, so in my opinion, you got
to start the legitimacy of talking to them and finding out what
they really believe in, you know? I don't know. I mean, I agree
with you. When he's on record of saying he loves, what does he
mean? If he genuinely if he genuinely loves Adolf, the blog's
a idiot, right? But but if he but if he's talking about, as you
put it, as you framed it, about what he may have been in, I don't
know. Um, but I'd be interested in having that conversation.
Um, in the same way that when I have Tate on, I agree with some
things Tate says, but I hammer him over his obvious misogyny.
I think the two, you know, someone can be right and wrong about
two things, right? Even Churchill, my great hero, wasn't right
about everything. If I was interviewing him, I would find some
things to criticize Winston Churchill about, right? It doesn't
mean to say I think he's a bad guy. I think he's an absolute
hero, my all-time hero. However, everybody is flawed. Right.
>> Right. Yeah. Yeah. And plus, if you were interviewing
Church Hill, he'd probably be drunk and you go, "Oh, well, I
guess that's true. No one is perfect." But I will say, yeah,
look, we need to be able to have these conversations. But this
litmus, these do matter. What have they done to defeat the left?
What have they done to fight the left? Can they build a coalition?
Something else that I think is pretty important. Can these people,
whether it's Ben Shapiro, whether it's the people who say they're
funded by Qar, these other people say you're a Zionist shill.
>> I'm getting super distracted by Steven Crowder's hairline.
Am I the only one? Can they take opinions at face value? Can
they take a disagreement without resorting to you're paid by
Israel? I can say this. Not one dime from a foreign nation. I
own every What's up with the hairlines recently?
It's like
No, no, no. It's not. It's just >> everything about this
company.
>> I've been here since 2009. >> Are you projecting?
Uh, no. Although, if I do bald, it'll be this way. >> I
was a blue bed sheet when there was no money out there. If people
say you're paid by X, in my experience, those are usually the
folks with something to hide something else too. I would call
and I would ask you to do this. Everyone out there, be transparent
with your references, with your sourcing. We provide a bibliography
every day. I know it's a lot more work, but you'll have a lot
of people who say, "I claim this and take my word for it." We
don't do that. So, if you put people through this filter, and
then you have to ask, what's the endgame for this? >> Did
any of these people like look at the topic? What What are you
yapping about? like you're just Hey, uh, this Fentes thing seems
to be popping off. What do you think of this guy? Well, I want
to I just want to go to a soap box about how conservatives don't
talk to each other anymore.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's go to the the guy, Matt Schlap. >> Chairman
of CPAC. Um, >> chairman of CPAC. I didn't know who this
was, but apparently this one's good. And then the last one is
Dan Krenshaw. >> Welcome to you, Matt. I mean, I've had
some fascinating conversations
uh with Benny Johnson, with Steven Crowder. um and with others
about where the conservative right is going. You're right in
the middle of all this. What do you feel is happening? >> Feel
interesting word that a conservative doesn't really ponder very
much. Uh I'll be honest with you, my feelings are fraught. I'm
anxious. I don't like um these public squables. Uh I'm looking
at the Democratic party embracing Marx Marxism and completely
crazy public policy and candidates. And I think the Democrats
that I know in Washington DC are really worried about what's
going on with their party, but yet publicly it seems like the
focus is on these splits in this Trump coalition. And you know
in cander I am very worried about the splits. >> How much
of that has been self-induced? And I would give as an example
the Epstein files and the way it's been handled. You know, I
mean, you whatever whatever emerges from these files, there's
no doubt that the
>> Trump administration before the election and in the
immediate aftermath were encouraging everyone
uh that they were going to release everything fully transparent
and so on and then suddenly the shutters come down. Now it looks
like they've been forced into doing a U-turn and now we're going
to have the files released and so on.
That has enraged a lot of people on the MAGA right. They really
feel let down by that. So I think there have been things the
Trump administration has done where their own team feel let down
by it.
>> It's just hard for me to fathom, Pierce, because I,
you know, I'm old. I'm a couple of years, I'll be 60 years old.
I got white hair. I've been doing this my whole life. The conservative
movement has never, and I say never, in my lifetime, and I love
Ronald Reagan, and I worked for President Bush, has never had
a president who was willing to go everywhere on everything
and make all the right people really upset. I always say all
the right people are sweating in Washington. It's a great, glorious
thing to behold. And it's been going on for a year now. Within
the course of that year, believe it or not, I'm a cheerleader
for President Trump because he's earned it. There are things
I disagree with. There are times that I would do things differently
than him. But after this near decade of him being this champion
on all the policies that I care about, um, am I going to look
for the needle in the haststack, the thing to be upset with him
about? That's that's the mentality I can't quite understand.
I understand that for a politician or for someone in the media,
you know, you're looking for attention and you're looking for
hits and there's no better way to get more attention, I suppose,
than saying Donald Trump is letting us down, but like logically,
how could that really even be a theme? I can't think of a policy
area where uh you know, Ted Williams is, you know, for Americans,
Pierce, Ted Williams is like the greatest baseball slugger of
all times. That was 400. Uh, you know, what is Donald Trump adding?
You know, 900 and that's not good enough. I I I just I >> I
guess what his critics would say, >> Jesus Christ, the
glaze.
THERE ISN'T EVEN A WALL. HOW THE [__] COULD HE RUN
on build the wall? There is no wall. And you say 90%.
900. HE'S BATTING 900.
WHAT? HOW? How in the world? say they'd say, "Look, this is somebody
who pledged not to engage in any more foreign wars, um, but has
committed more funding to Ukraine in their war against Russia,
has committed endless funding to Israel in the war against bombed
Iran, is now threatening military attack on Venezuela." They
think that's inconsistent. They look at the inflation situation
a year in and they say a lot of food prices and so on are higher
uh than they were at the start of the year. They feel let down
by that. Um Epstein files went from transparency to low transparency
to now potentially transparency. So there are a few things there
where I can understand
why critics have looked at that and gone well they said one people
on the right. Sorry, we're skipping up the cancel culture. >> For
years have been quite rightly railing against what they see as
the woke ideology tendency to cancel >> I'll be I'll be
honest. Um
I'm [__] I'm still dying. I'm like actually sick.
I didn't realize how sick I was until I got home. I'm actually
very sick. >> And deplatforming and so on. Everybody on
the right they didn't like. Is there a danger that by suppressing
somebody like Fuentes >> to pin that? I didn't mean to
pin that. If I pinned it, I can't see who pinned it. So, I'm
going to unpin it. >> The right stop behaving in the same
way. >> You know, we look at all these questions every
year. We have our big conference every year, and then we have
other events. And, you know, we're always asking ourselves that
question. I mean, I've had Van Jones and some really far-left
people on the stage, but it they weren't on because they were
left wingers. They were on because we were working together on
some public policy. you know, if uh if somebody who's a provocator
online
actually got serious and wanted to work on some kind of public
policy, I mean, I think I've I take a meeting with almost anybody
to discuss almost anything. But there also are there are lines
that are crossed, right? And uh my uh feeling is when it comes
to equations of bigotry
um and hatred that it's fair to it's fair to say, you know what,
we're not going there this year. Doesn't mean that they don't
have the right to speak. I don't really have that much power
in the scheme of things. We're not a big media company. I'm not
saying they should be cancelled. I'm not saying they should never
get a job. I don't want their family to be harmed. But, you know,
does what their message really fit into the CPAC message? I think
it's a very fair question for us to ask. And when it comes to
Nick Fuentes, we don't feel like there's been enough harmony
to be able to have him on stage. And I will say specifically,
I don't know understand the anim if you're not an >> What
do you mean harmony to you guys? You guys have just had him banned
for for like ever.
Where's the where could the harmony come >> Anti-semite.
Why so much animosity towards Israel? I mean there there there
doesn't seem to be this animosity. >> Listen, we need harmony
on this one issue. Okay. >> Towards other countries that
we have substantial disagreements with or some minor disagreements.
So it's a very fair challenge for people to say, you know, is
it just a strategic question or do you have a problem with there
being a a state? I don't have a problem with there being a state.
It's a bit of a unique thing obviously, but I don't have a problem
with that because we tried it the other way and uh and the pograms
and the persecution
um you know are are diabolical.
>> Okay. So, you're going to start making a Kurdish state
now.
Is that what you're going to on moral grounds you feel like there
should be a Kurdish state? Obviously, right? He thinks there
should be a Kurdish state >> and historic and uh you know
the civilization at the time and the countries at that time said
we have to give the the people their own state and and and for
whatever reason I see it woven in the Bible but there is other
reasons as well the state
>> why you trying to pipe right now Chris what are you
doing what are you doing >> views America as its most important
strategic ally and I think that is a good thing not a bad thing
>> yeah I mean I just don't think for example example,
somebody like me who supported Israel's right to defend itself
after October the 7th, but then became increasingly critical
of the way that Israel was prosecuting the war against terrorist.
Um, I don't understand why that means I suddenly become anti-semitic.
I wasn't accused of being anti-semitic when I supported Israel's
right to defend itself. And I I do think that has been an ugly
side of the debate on that particular war. You should be free
to criticize governments and their decisions without being branded
somebody who hates the people of that country. >> Well,
first of all, uh you would be very welcome on the CPAC stage,
Pierce. And I think that one of the things we have to do as we
get closer to our big conference is thinking about a way to talk
about this in a constructive manner. I think uh Stephen I heard
a bit of that conversation and you know I think it is true which
is you have a lot of young men who feel very unattached
to success in America. They don't feel like they're treated uh
in the same legal way that there's a two-tiered system of justice
and they are increasingly
following more striden voices. And I think one of the things
we ought to do is instead of calling each other names, I don't
know what that accomplishes. And by the way, I'm not the guy
who gets to determine who's anti-Semitic or not. I mean, I can
have my own opinions, but I think what you just said, if you
have a real disagreement with Prime Minister Netanyahu, or you
have a real disagreement with Israeli public policy, and you
express that publicly, you have every right to do that. And I
think disagreeing with the leaders of the of Israel, I don't
think that makes you anti-Semitic. think when you get to I think
when you get into the range where people start to hurl that uh
invective is when you seem to just have a hostility towards Israel,
right? Or when you're always against them on everything or you
talk about your hatred for their policy constantly. And I think
when it comes to October 7th, the only thing I will say is that
um that was a you know a historically evil malign attack. I've
watched I went to the strip near the Gaza Strip with some of
the survivors of the attack and I watched all these videos uh
that have been pulled together and you know we can't kind of
sugarcoat the fact that there is a radicalized Muslim effort
to wipe Israel off the face of the earth and they have to live
with that reality and I think as Americans we have to understand
we have to live with that reality too because they want to wipe
us off the face of the earth. Now, having said that, there still
have to be protocols and a humanitarian approach to how you handle
>> that conflict. And I worked for President Bush, one
of the things that we decided to do is that we would wipe them
from the face of the earth. And I think looking back on it all
these many years ago, >> dude, how hard is it to just be
like, "Hey, what do you think of this Fuentes guy?" and just
answer honestly. I get this guy did it. Why are they dragging
it out with all these people? It's kind of crazy. Um, I feel
quite bad. I'll see tomorrow about doing like a longer stream
or the next day. I'm sorry that I'm so sick right now. I'm like
not I'm not I'm kind of phoning it in. It's my first stream back.
I feel really bad. I apologize, guys. Okay. I'll feel better
tomorrow or the next day. I My bad, man.
My bad. I just feel I feel bad. Why would you apologize? Cuz
I have been gone for like multiple days and now I'm just sick.
Cold season. Yeah.
Um, do I try? I'm going to try to get through Cshaw. Let's get
on to Cshaw. >> We were a little >> Let's do Cshaw
and then I'm going to >> America first means and what MAGA
represents with his views on the apparent collapse in the MAGA
coalition. I'm joined by Texas Congressman and former US Navy
Seal Dan Krenshaw. Dan, welcome back to Uncensored. Good to see
you. Um, what is going on with the MAGA movement? Is it is it
fragmenting irrevocably? Are you seeing Ben Shapiro and the likes
of Ben on one side, the Tucker Carlson and Candy on the others
splitting the whole MAGA thing in two in a way it can never be
repaired? >> I I think that's giving one side way too much
credit. I think there's a lot of adults talking in the room and
there's a there's a toddler or two screaming in the corner begging
for attention. That's really what this split is. I mean, look,
it appears, you know, that I I've been >> I mean, no offense,
the toddlers don't normally get
like they don't normally have a platform that outsizes the adults.
Like, imagine if the toddlers had the bank accounts that were
the equivalent of like every other adult in the room. That's
what's happening here. I feel like there's a problem you guys
have that you are totally coping on right now.
I'm sorry. That's crazy. Like if this guy was like if this guy
planned for a week to do a live stream, he couldn't get 1,000th
the views that Fuentes and Candace and Tucker get, right? I He
just doesn't >> Fighting this for a long time. Uh I'm really
happy that a lot of other people are now fighting the the same
battle, but it really is against a very small faction. Um you
named a couple, Tucker Tucker Carlson, Candace Owens. Who are
these people? These aren't there's no ideological split really.
I mean, yeah. Yes. Tucker does believe in some things that regular
conservatives definitely do not. I mean, he's he's on the record
very recently even talking about his economic policies, agreeing
more with Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders more than conservatives.
Uh, you know, you could go down the list, but what what what
he really is and what Candace really is are contrarians.
That's what they are. They're attention seekers. They're they're
click chasers. And they also know something. And they knew they've
they've known that especially since he got fired from Fox that
he could corner a certain market. The Gropers, you know, that
Nick Fuentes group, the alt-rights, the Qan honors, those are
names you haven't heard in a while. But remember, those people
never went anywhere and they needed a home. And so I think Tucker
knew that. >> Ripers have never gone down in size like
the entire they've never the alt-right disappeared. The QAnon
thing disappeared.
Ripers have been around the whole time >> from a from from
a business media perspective. And I think a lot of influencers
know that who pedal this kind of stuff. So I would not call this
a split. A split implies that it's this 50-50 split. And that
is just I I just don't think that's the case at all when when
you look at the members who are actually elected when you look
at President Trump's policies and statements. What is what I
I think is fermenting the idea of a growing unrest amongst even
the most diehard MAGA Trump supporters is the whole issue of
transparency. Whether it relates to the Epstein files, whether
it relates to the attempted assassin, uh Thomas Crooks of Donald
Trump, you know, whether it relates to JFK files, all the other
things, all the things which they said they were going to be
fully transparent about. Um, you know, the the shooting of Charlie
Kirk is another one that's fueling a lot of conspiracy theories
because of the lack of information.
Should this administration be a lot more transparent they're
being? And why aren't they being what they said they would be?
>> I'm not sure I agree with the premise there on every
single one of those
>> Okay,
I [clears throat] think that was total cope. All right, I'm gonna
I'm gonna end there. I
like I said, I'm I'm kind of falling apart, so
Let me see if I got anyone I can host. Tree. We'll host Tree.
Go talk to Tree. I'm out, guys. I'll see you all later. Okay.
Um, I'll make up this time tomorrow as well. Hold on. Let me
pause the timer. I'll make up this time tomorrow. Okay. Have
a good night, everybody. I'll be back.
Bye-bye. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. Oh,
I got to host trade. There we go. Hosting.